without further Ado I'm going to uh open
the hearing
on the amendment
and I'm going to recognize
representative true to come and
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record I am Chris true
representing Rockingham District 9 the
town of Sandown thank you for allowing
me to introduce this amendment
this amendment before you does
principally two things
first it allows New Hampshire citizens
who scuba dive a small four-week minimum
period somewhere during the months of
April through September to take no more
than three lobsters a day
for their personal consumption
scuba divers currently are allowed to
dive for crabs and scallops in New
Hampshire with no reported safety or
enforcement issues in these same Waters
the Amendment sets a cap of 100 licenses
and stipulates that lobsters must be
caught by hand measured on the ocean
floor be of legal size and sex and most
importantly caught only in the
designated areas
the second goal the amendment is to
close a loophole on our statutes that
has hampered New Hampshire but not Maine
from following many other Atlantic
states who are doing environmental
cleanup of their Coastal Waters our
Coastal waters are littered with
countless numbers of lost or disguided
pieces of fishing gear
whether the fishing gear is called
derelict abandoned or ghost it remains
to be just plain trash
my goal should be to clean up our
Coastline of this underwater trash the
loophole currently prevents us from
cleaning up the trash in an efficient
manner
the statue was put in place to prevent
commercial lobstermen from messing with
each other's traps it says essentially
no one can touch another's fishing gear
unless they have the owner's permission
or they are a New Hampshire conservation
officer that law prevents law-abiding
scuba divers from touching the traps to
identify their owner or indoor to attach
surface lines so the garbage can be
lifted up to the surface and dispose of
an orderly fashion
this amendment allows New Hampshire to
begin the arduous task of cleaning up
our Coastal Waters in the most efficient
manner possible
efficient in two senses first in terms
of cost using volunteer divers is
tremendously cost effective but secondly
the amendment the efficiency is to use
scuba divers eyes on the situation to
First locate and then report the
location with fish and game and then
assist with the actual cleanup
you will hear much more about the
process from Key Witnesses who runs a
not-for-profit company in Maine doing
just this
it is a much better system than dragging
a heavy damaged grappling hook and the
haphazard blind luck manner in the hopes
of snagging and abandoning an abandoned
lobster trap
the fact that they catch some traps is
only Testament to the fact that ocean
water is not teeming with garbage
beneath the waves
New Hampshire divers I'm asking for this
law good citizens and they have
environmentalists they see that the
garbage that needs cleaning up and are
seeking to be part of the solution they
witness firsthand the captive lobsters
and fish that remain in derelict lobster
traps that need to be released into the
wild
they are asking permission to catch by
hand three lobsters for their own
consumption and in doing so participate
in the sport that has allowed and
encouraged all Atlantic Coastal States
except in New Hampshire
in Maine
by the way of explanation for just how
ridiculous the arguments have in
opposition to the sport I offer four
facts one the government reports the
Atlantic states marine fisheries
Commission report
containing 500 pages was last completed
in 2021
that report States the vast majority of
Landings came from Gulf of Maine and
Georgia's Bank where the stock of
lobsters is at record high abundance
to the same report says Lobster pots
predominantly commercial Gear with small
percentage of The Landings caught by
trolls
Lobster is also taken recreationally
with pots and by hand while scuba diver
Bob scuba diving the overall quantity of
recreational Landing is unknown but is
likely to be a negligible source of
removals
three Massachusetts who has allowed
recreational scuba diving for as long as
anyone can remember allows divers to
dive year round and take up to 15
lobsters per day they keep very good
records They report the average scuba
diver license holder spends 13.2 hours
of diving for lobster they average 0.9
lobsters per hour less than one per hour
Massachusetts sold 1425 scuba permits
last year
we are asking for 100.
they have provided us with a positive
report about enforcement and their
program is whole
as it is uh has every other state we
contacted about the state's diver
program no issues
we should have received written comments
from your chair
you should have received written
comments for me a chair from both
Massachusetts and Rhode Island to that
effect lastly
just something to consider New Hampshire
currently sells non-residents commercial
Lobster licenses for six hundred dollars
so a commercial business originating in
Maine can come to New Hampshire and pay
600 for a license we'll pay his home
state 888 for a comparable license
if we look at the reverse situation if a
New Hampshire Commercial Business wanted
a Min non-resident Lobster license it
would cost twenty eight hundred and
eighty dollars we think a New Hampshire
resident scuba diver is at least worthy
of being able to enjoy this natural
resource as a non-resident Commercial
Business from Maine in Massachusetts
the mission of a fish and game
department says conserve manage protect
these resources in their habitats and
provide public with opportunities to use
and appreciate these resources
from what the mission statements doesn't
say is probably more to the point it
doesn't say provide out-of-state
businesses with the opportunity to
profit from our resources and leave
trash in the waters I will leave you
with this one thought if this bill
passes every scuba diver
uh was successful as the Massachusetts
divers then New Hampshire divers
couldn't possibly equal 1 100th of the
production of just one of the
non-residential commercial Lobster
license holders
thank you for the time I don't know how
much uh lobsters expect I think I don't
know much about lobsters except they are
delicious and in some places they look
much different but I won't eat them
my business partner Ian Hill and I I'm
speaking for Greg Hill I only eat uh
Maine Lobsters after writing a
complicated computer programs that's all
I know about that so I am
reading for respectfully from
representative Greg Hill Merrimack too I
believe I've taken enough of your time I
won't take any questions in the interest
of time because if I took more time that
a chair recognizes Jim tetone
representing or from Seabrook New
Hampshire uh he's asked for five minutes
thank you
good morning
my name is Jim tatone I'm from Seabrook
New Hampshire I'm a commercial
lobsterman
I'm representing today the Yankee
Fisherman's co-op in Seabrook and it's
60 plus members who are in opposition to
the uh the lobster industry right now
was facing many challenges we have uh
we have environmental challenges we have
challenges where this potential
industrialization of a plenty of ocean
bottom and we have the regulatory
challenges we have
currently there are over 13
000 regulations that govern commercial
fishing
that's opposed to the oil and gas
exploration industry which only has 12
000 regulations to comply with and
pharmaceutical manufacturing that has a
little more than 11 000 regulations
so commercial fishing is one of the most
regulated Industries in this country
but the majority of the uh regulations
pertaining to commercial fishing deals
with sustainability of the different
species that we land that help feed
America
and in the Gulf of Maine
we uh we're fortunate to have plenty of
scientists who um who do plenty of
research on how to sustain the lobster
population
and the main contributor to the Lobster
sustainability is abated lobster trap
it's been proven through scientific
research that allops bated lobster trap
is the main source of food for lobsters
now I've I've been searching for any
kind of scientific research where it
indicates that the taking of lobsters by
the diving activity
contributes to the sustainability of the
lobster resource and there's no no
information out there at all no
scientific evidence that this is a
contribution to the sustainability of
this important resource
now we've heard testimony in the past
here from proponents of this bill that
this lops the bill if it would pass
would allow the taking of four to five
thousand lobsters that's four to five
thousand lobsters that are taken in an
unsustainable manner
another one of the challenges we're
facing right now and we'll get probably
heard a lot about them news is the
decline since 2012 of the juvenile
Lobster settlement to the bottom of the
ocean
now I'm gonna in relation in relative to
the juvenile Lobster recruitment
scientific Studies have shown that
shelter occupancy by post-lava lobsters
in near shore Rocky environments is
critically important to the
sustainability of the juvenile Lobster
stock to reduce the risk of predation
from uh the other species now the New
Hampshire coastal areas proposed by this
bill
for the taking of lobsters by diving are
the same near shore Rocky bottom that
where a majority of the juvenile Ops to
settle
in the search for Lobsters by divers
there's trouble turning rocks and large
or small Boulders exposing these
juveniles to predation
so we have a situation here we have a
activity that doesn't contribute to the
sustainability of a valuable resource is
a deterrent to the sustainability of the
resource as it exposes our juvenile
Lobster population to increase risk of
predation
now
the regulatory requirements that are
imposed upon the law of the fishermen we
have all the requirements on our
shoulders
to be to assure the sustainability of
this valuable resource and there's no
responsibility whatsoever for the taking
a dialopsis by diving to have contribute
to the sustainability of this of this
thing so we have a non-contribution to
the sustainability of the lobster we
have a deterrent to the contribution to
the sustainability of Lobster by
exposing juveniles to predation and we
have a house bill here that contains
even more regulations for the lobster
fishing industry that are totally
unenforceable
now the mission of the fish and game
department is to protect and preserve
all our natural resources especially the
lobster resource this house bill does
neither of those
everybody every resident of this state
has the opportunity to exploit the
lobster resource and that's through a
sustainable manner of the Trap fishery
and if you're gonna sit if you if you
want to be able to exploit the resource
do it in a sustainable Manner and that
is the Trap Fishery so that's my
testimony for today I'll be more than
happy to answer anybody's questions
thank you sir are there any questions
you recognized representative
thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question
tell us uh there's a big argument that
Massachusetts and Maine does this you
know the whatever the bill is asking for
tell me that how big is the main cost
and how big is the Massachusetts coast
and what we have here in New Hampshire
well in in Maine there's a Prohibition
he gets diving for lobsters
Massachusetts has been a there's been a
law in effect for that allows the uh
diving for offices but you're talking
States
for basically Cape Ann Cape Ann has more
coastline than the state of New
Hampshire and that's just that one small
portion of the state of Massachusetts so
Massachusetts has extensive Coastline
that can that's um that can be allowed
for the technical offices we just don't
have it and like I said the bottom that
would be open to the diving for Law
Offices is the same bottom where the
juvenile offices settle and that bottom
gets Disturbed and we're going to have
our juvenile stock subject to uh
additional predation and we all know
that the decline the decline in the
settlement of the law juvenile office
has been a serious problem
follow-up Mr chairman follow-up
did you hear that the 17 or 18 Mile
Coastline we have in New Hampshire we
are very proud of our what we have and
that is our Crown Jewel
basically it is yeah we have such a
short Coastline we need to do all we can
to protect the resources that we derive
from the small bit of Coastline that we
do have
thank you
thank you any other questions
representative Tudor
could you tell me do you fish the same
area that is being proposed for the
scuba diver I do there are certain times
of the year where I am fishing in that
uh near Shore Water sometimes in seven
to ten feet of water follow up Mr chair
follow up and can you tell me what the
difference would be from dragging a trap
across the bottom from a to a dive of
turning over rocks on the bottom well
generally what you're doing is you're
you're moving you both forward so you're
not dragging your traps across the
bottom because if you do happen to be in
a circumstance of dragging the traps you
could get the Trap hung up on a large
Rock and the Rope could possibly snap so
what you do is when you're in the
shallow bottom you keep moving your boat
forward so you have a direct access from
where the Trap is right up to the boat
so you prevent the dragging because you
don't want to get those traps hung up in
any rocks because you there's a
thank you any other questions
representative Smith
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just following up on
the other representative's question
regarding the traps bouncing across the
ocean floor what is the weight of a
lobster trap well it depends what size
of the Trap if you have a three foot
trap it's probably
um 40 pounds and a four foot trap would
probably be maybe 50 50 pounds
follow-up follow-up so you're saying
your intention is to not drag a trap
across the ocean floor which I
understand but obviously you can't see
Into the Depths if that trap is being
dragged across the ocean floor well if
if you're in if you're fishing in near
shore sections and you're in seven to
ten feet of water yeah you can tell just
by where your lines are going where that
trap is and you basically follow that
line with your boat to make sure that
you don't get that trap snagged up in
any potential rocks that are on the
bottom there one more follow-up one more
isn't it also true that traps get left
in the ocean for a period of time and
When Storms come in they get bounced
around by the weather the currents
disturbing the ocean floor much more
than a diver my the entire ocean floor
especially near shore gets Disturbed
when you have large storms it's not only
from the traps but the wave action
that's actually if you've drove down or
uh along the coast you can see how many
rocks this past year have been thrown up
from the ocean during some of those
large storms we've had so it's just not
the traps alone that would be disturbing
the bottom Mother Nature itself is going
to cause more damage than any of these
traps thank you
any other questions not seeing any thank
you very much for your testimony
thanks for the opportunity
the chair now recognizes Michael
Flanagan
uh from Rye representing himself and
opposes the bill
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee
uh my name is Michael Flanagan Ryan New
Hampshire I've been a full-time
commercial fisherman for 68 years
I've never had any Fisheries violation
state or federal I'm the treasurer New
Hampshire commercial Fisherman's
Association
a member of the Maine Lobsters
Association down east Lobster's
Association Mass lobsters Association
I'm a past member of the Atlantic
offshore Association
and also a member of the Cape Cod
Fisherman's Association
I'm speaking today on behalf of myself
and my family
my brother and I both hold 1200 trap
licenses with a very active commercial
fishermen
my two sons on a wholesale Lobster
buying off an air freight
Lobster business in Kittery Maine I've
been involved in offshore operating for
20 years 1980 to 2000. as well as
in-shore lobstering in New Hampshire
I don't have his offshore I fished out
of Newport Rhode Island Fairhaven Mass
I'm not anti-diver I respect divers very
I'm opposed to diving for lobsters
because it's against the law
page five and the bottom column taking
Lobster by diving angling sparing is
against the law on the right hand side
leave Lobster pots alone Lobster pots
traps walks ropes cars boys a private
property regardless of the locations
includes on the beach and on the Rocks
no person except the owner or
conservation officer May possess lift
molester disturb them to do so may
result in a finer two thousand dollars
after one year in jail
I didn't make that up that's in the law
book
from the left-hand column
poaching lobsters is a crime this is a
New Hampshire law book I didn't make
this up took a lot of years for the
thank you very much your time any
questions I'd be glad to answer them
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today one additional thing fellow spoke
about dragging the traps across the
motion across the bottom of the ocean
that's absurd when you hold the Lobster
Pot draw a string whatever you want to
call it you want the boat has to stay up
on the line vertically we're lifting
these traps vertically up we're not
dragging them across the ocean we lift
them off the bottom of the ocean thank
you sir you drag your traps around
that's one of the other problems these
things are very very expensive now it
damages your traps to drag them across
the ocean that's a false one
the chair will now call
Ward bird
uh representing industry
from East Brentwood and uh opposes the
to uh
thank you for uh letting me have some
testimony this morning and uh
there's a lot of uh
misinformation I I heard the gentleman
that
read out the bill New Hampshire does not
allow non-residents to Lobster fish in
New Hampshire
I believe he said they did that's just
not true
um
as Mr Flanagan said we lift traps off
the bottom we don't
hmm
we don't drag them
our traps are approximately 150 a piece
if you drag a trap across the bottom it
peels the vinyl off the Trap exposes the
wire and our traps brought out period so
it's in our best interest to lift them
not drag him
talk about this bill as a whole we had
the original bill
then we had an amendment and now we have
another amendment
I I it really makes me wonder what's
going on here we've turned in from
diving from lopses
to set and Regulatory measures against
our industry
uh
uh I don't know if this
group knows what we are going through
with windmills in our future
what it what happens to us in 10 years
when they want to put windmills off our
Coast what happens to my living what
happens to all these fishermen's living
what happens that
yet you want to create another
regulatory measure right whales we've
been regulated to death on that we've
met every requirement
by the NOAA in National marine fisheries
to make our
we need your help we don't need this
hindrance of uh it's like a this bill is
like a a little dog chewing at our ankle
compared to the global giants that are
attacking us on a daily basis
I don't know if anybody in this room
seen what's happening down south of us
right now in New Jersey with seismic
testing for windmills is killing whales
hand over fist to the degree of 34
something whales
we need your help we don't need more
regulations more red tape more
taking from what we've already regulated
fish and game has done a fine job
setting regulations in this state
and another layer of an area where
you're going to close off bottom so
individuals can take three lobsters it's
just
it's just gone too far I'm I I've had it
I got to tell you right now it's like
every direction we're coming from if
you're a fisherman you're under the gun
and we're just trying to make an honest
living
the time that's been spent by
individuals in this room a Damon
Frampton a Bobby nud
and Eric Anderson have spent countless
thousands of hours
working on making us a better industry
we need your help we don't need any more
we can't take anymore our fuel prices
are through the roof uh bait prices are
through the roof and uh Fuel and our
expenses have just they've tripled
and yet uh Lobster prices have dwindled
last year as a whole
this Lobster industry in New Hampshire I
can safely say made half of what we made
the year before half of our income yet
our expenses tripled
I think this bill is a bogus bill I
think it needs to be thrown out
and let us do uh thing fishing thank you
chair now calls David Coyle
um
asking for five minutes and in favor of
the bill and says you have written
testimony
where it's checked off saying that
is there no written testimony I'll just
are you writing the testimony though or
is it
oh okay it's already submitted thank you
yep
okay thank you for coming today and uh
if you could turn the mic on that
can you hear it now yep
thank you everybody for allowing me to
speak with you
um
a large part of why I've gotten involved
in this is somebody came up to me and
said if you don't like the way the law
is do something to change it so that's
kind of why I'm here
um the um
everything has gotten more difficult
um in in our the way we're living so I
do sympathize for the lobstermen we are
not trying to damage their industry we
are only looking to be able to help any
way that we can
I have come to this meeting and I've
talked about how when I go scuba diving
and I've seen things in lobster traps
and I am the people the person that is
talking and training people how to scuba
dive and telling them that we are not
able to be able to help to be able to
move their lobster traps I went um a
couple weekends ago we went out and we
went diving just to see how many lobster
traps they were abandoned that we could
find and we found a bunch and we've um
I've taken pictures of them so that you
could see them
um and so what we'd like to do is is to
be able to help our oceans how to be
able to remove them you're going to hear
testimony today of an organization
that's been in Maine that's working very
well
um and I'd like to be able to see if I
can help out work with the loftsman work
with the the fishing game
um to be able to have a better community
and help support the sustaining of the
lobsters and also be able to be able to
take a small amount of lobsters as if I
was a um doing a five Pot
Limit that I can do now as a resident
I would have very little to be able to
see what's under the water to see what
is going down when I am going scuba
diving I can see the lobsters I don't
have to even touch them to see if
they're too small a lot of times they
are in holes and they're hiding during
the day because they come out during the
night that's why the traps do do very
well because they're they're nocturnal
they come out at night and they are able
to do a go into the traps and I'm
feeding that way when we're going during
the day we're just looking for the ones
that are not hiding we're not disturbing
the bottom we're stewards of the ocean
and that's a large part that I take very
serious that we want to be able to
educate and help our community as well
thank you sir any questions
yes
thank you Mr chair one quick question
do the majority of divers carry some
sort of GPS with them when they're
diving they don't have a GPS GPS doesn't
work underwater
follow-up
thank you Mr chair
so my question goes to the amendment we
you shall report the location of a pot
trap or car that you locate yeah how
will you go about putting a location if
you don't use GPS so what what I'd like
to be able to do is we have a um a water
bottle that would be empty
um I could carry it with me and have a
rope that would be attached that I could
if I see lobster traps that are
abandoned I could if we painted it
orange we could deploy that by adding
air to it to be able to send it to the
surface then the lobster men would be
able to retrieve it that way or you
could come to the surface and then you
could use your phone to create a um a
GPS system on the surface but not
underwater
representative Brown
uh thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
are all divers capable of doing what you
said that you do which is not disturbing
the lobster population
while taking them I I believe at the
last hearing we heard some from fish and
game that there was the potential for
loss of claw and um disturbing juveniles
so that they wouldn't
uh they wouldn't uh continue to survive
yeah and that's kind of what I wanted to
get involved in this is to be able to
educate if there's people out and
they're taking lobsters now they're
doing it illegal I think that was
something that was done more in the past
I don't know of anybody that's going out
for lobsters
um as of now because they know it's
illegal
um if they were to be able to do it I
would like to work with fish and game
and come up with a program
um a grandma and myself are actually
talking about just doing one anyway to
be able to create a a lobster awareness
um the an ecology program to be able to
help people understand more about
lobsters and their habitat
seeing none thank you for your testimony
chair will now call Buzz Scott from
Newcastle Maine
and it doesn't say whether you support
or oppose the bill we'll check that off
for you if you'll let me know okay
um I think I uh might speak for both
sides so oh I don't know if I uh we'll
leave it blank then should even put
something in there uh my name is Buzz
Scott I'm from Newcastle Maine I uh I'm
the founder of Ocean's wide which is a
an educational program uh designed after
I worked as a commercial fisherman for
17 years on the coast of Maine
I also when I was working as a
commercial fisherman I was told to leave
the island get out and see the rest of
the world so that I could come back and
make the state of Maine a better place I
didn't know how I was going to do that
but after you know a number of years I'm
62 now I realized that I could come back
and help by educating young people like
I was when I was a fisherman
I wanted to help them explore the ocean
I was a Navy Seabee I was working for
the U.S Antarctic program on board their
research vessels and later in life for
the last 25 years I've been flying
remotely operated unmanned submarines
rovs for research in waters around the
world and as I was doing that I was
seeing a lot of things on the bottom of
the ocean and I thought my gosh we got a
we got a problem here and and I continue
to do the ROV work I still do on
occasion but I wanted to come back and
teach the kids about ocean exploration
and adventure and and basically learning
more about what they can do to protect
the ocean environment I came back we
started teaching kids how to scuba dive
we taught in how to drive rovs and run
boats and as we were down there these
students were seeing
a lot of traps on the bottom littering
the bottom and these were we were going
out during the time when the fishermen
either had their gear offshore or up and
so the traps that we were seeing were
all
um either derelict or abandoned or ghost
gear whatever you want to call them and
uh our students students from Maine
students from New York students from
South Carolina all said we've got to do
something about this so I asked one of
our students two of our students who
were fishermen to go out and talk to
their community and ask if you know is
can we can we collect any of your traps
and they went out in two days they came
back with a thousand traps these are
Shore based traps and the reason we did
shorebase first is because I wanted to
make sure that we were supporting the
fishing community and I wanted to see if
they had traps that they wanted to get
rid of but were unable to
they found a thousand traps in two days
and said that they could have ten
thousand traps in a month and I said wow
so we started a land-based program where
we took traps from the fishermen they
brought them to us and we broke them
apart and crushed them and recycled them
and uh and then the word got out that we
were doing this and a Gentleman came to
us from Boothbay Harbor and said would
you like to go underwater and see what's
down there and I said well absolutely we
had the support of the fishermen to do
that we we talked to them quite often
and we started out by doing surveys so
we surveyed the bottom to see how many
traps we could find in 18 days we found
850 in just Boothbay Harbor in a one
mile radius
we started taking those traps up and
since then we've taken up 2700 traps
roughly 2 700 traps from the Boothbay
Harbor area and we've disposed of those
there are probably 10 times that on the
bottom in that one Harbor and one one
local location
um
we're working to do that again in other
locations matinicus Island where I grew
up Stonington Maine
Boothbay has about 120 fishermen
Stonington has 450. jonesport has
another 350 and so you can imagine the
amount of traps that are on the bottom
in the in the Gulf of Maine and we're
trying to do our best to take them up
numbers that can help 20 percent of the
traps that we take out
are still fishable some of them are like
new
about two-thirds of the traps that we
take up have animals in them
we we do
um
we do release the animals and set them
free but you've got everything and I've
got a list of the animals that we've
taken out of these traps and and
the traps are coated in plastic
everybody knows that this is a problem
Plastics in the ocean are killing
animals and so the more traps we get out
of the water the more we can support the
fishing community and support the
thank you sir thank you I assume you're
willing to take questions if we have any
absolutely do we have any questions
representative Smith
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you said two-thirds
of the traps have animals in them that's
correct can you just give a quick brief
summary of the type of animals and if
they're alive or mostly dead
yes uh so we have we've caught lobster
crab Cod we've got one Cod uh flat fish
we get a number of them Connor are very
um often found in these straps uh sculp
and sea Robbins
urchins Rock tunnels sea cucumbers
mussels of course are growing on the
traps themselves and we have sea stars
and uh sand dollars and the kinds of
any any further yes Vice chair
thank you Mr chairman
I guess I want to follow up on that and
because you said two-thirds have animals
but we're hearing
that list goes on and on how many
actually have lobsters in them when
you're bringing them up uh I'm gonna say
half those traps the third of the traps
that we pick out some of them have four
of them four or five of them you know
I've hauled out four really nice select
lobsters out of a trap
um and uh and that's not that's a very
common
uh
rep Ford
thank you chairman
um
two questions
um you said 2700 out of Boothbay
um do you have what's the time frame for
that how how many days uh how many days
I can't really give you that but we've
been doing it since uh 2020. okay uh we
work in the spring before the fishermen
put their gear in and then again in the
fall after they've gone offshore that's
um and then can I follow up Sir
follow-up thank you chairman
um
I'm learning a lot
about traps and lobsters and all such
and I learned that waves and storms can
wash traps around
from your expertise where are these all
main lobster traps are they all from
Boothbay like where are they from
imagining we have a very small Shoreline
and traps are getting washed to and from
across our shorelines all the time so
I'm just wondering where you found these
traps to be from or they're typically
local traps within you know they they
move around a couple hundred yards maybe
in the storms especially and then they
wash up on the shore we wash up over
Ledges we found one area with uh is
about the size of a football field and
there were 300 traps taken out and
probably that amount left there to be
any other questions yes representative
page
and then hold on representative page
first then pair
so we've heard a testimony about
more modern traps having biodegradable
material to allow
uh new creatures to Escape right
with the derelict gear that you found in
Boothbay that has all of these different
creatures in it
are those older traps or are those
current traps that should be allowing
those those creatures to escape I just
on top of the um the rocky bottom
and the Escape vents do just what
they're designed to do they break away
the mild steel hog rings
dissolve and they break away the animals
are allowed to get out of those traps
there are also Sandy Bottom and Muddy
Bottom where the traps sink into the
sediment and I've got some pictures of
that if you'd like to see those
and sometimes they'll trap that escape
vent so even if it does even if they do
rot away they stay in in place and it
doesn't open up for the fish to get out
of the animals to get out
the age of the traps they range from
representative Perry
uh yes thank you Mr chair I don't know
if you're the right person to ask but
I'll ask anyway are these things that
you found in the excuse me this the
derelict traps typical of I of creatures
that also end up in excuse me active
active traps that are being fished on a
regular basis
I'd like the fishermen to talk to that
but uh I would guess so
thank you
okay any other questions
representative Brown
so I want to see if you can thank you Mr
chair sorry and thanks for taking my
question see if you can clarify for me
because I think
to make sure that I didn't misunderstand
there is plastic on lobster traps that's
correct that could come off
and then in the next sentence you said
there's a lot of problems with Plastics
in the oceans and do you have a
correlation or is is there to make sure
that we're not placing blame where it
shouldn't be
do you have an exact correlation of that
or is that just a a statement that
that's a statement there's plastic and
that is a plastic problem and yeah so
PVC they're coated in PVC
um and that is negatively buoyant so it
sinks to the bottom and uh I have some
scientific papers here that I can share
with you as well
um and I will get the answer here in a
second but uh any PVC any Plastics in
the ocean is bad and the more we take
out the better off our resources are
going to be the healthier our oceans are
going to be direct correlation no I
don't have that and I can't tell you
that because we don't know how much
plastic is in the ocean actually
I just want to address this situation
sir uh we don't take questions unless
you're actually recognized to speak so I
well we can get to that but not at this
point when somebody's speaking so I just
wanna
that's thank you very much I'd like to
take that question because I can answer
that then it should have been mentioned
if you would like him to join you at the
table he can ask his question or make
his comment and then you can you can
answer to it
um so if you'd like to step forward so
you're at the microphone sir you can go
ahead and and um
it's probably valuable to the committee
I think with this fellow spoke about it
very true
I don't want to
belittle the enforcement in the state of
Maine these are this Escape vent from a
trap this is what he speaks about if
they're installed properly and trapped
they work very very well I could pass
this around the room this would be the
the Escape vent in the top of the Trap
one side faster with stainless steel
rings the other side faster
biodegradable steel rings
the way things are now water temperature
are cheap cheap Chinese steel rings they
last about 10 months that door falls
open they work perfectly well the Trap
they have to be they're required in all
the traps so he's finding a lot of traps
without these that's an Enforcement
issue with the different states but
that's I'd like to pass this around the
room so you people could see it you can
pass that around the room and I'll let
you address the thing now issue that was
brought up is is that uh is that vent in
uh in the door
I wish Maine did that I wish Maine did
that they put the Escape vents on the
sides and and that's very different a
lot of times they will put a uh a piece
of wood lath in there
um so it would it would uh the lab would
stay until it was in the water for six
or eight months and then it would
dissolve away and that would allow the
animal to get out of the Trap so yes
those are very good Escape vents
I wish there were more of them
any other representative Ford
thank you chairman um
I I guess I I'm I'm straightforward in
your opinion this bill will it help or
hurt the issues in which you see in
Maine
the issues the the
Lost ghosts traps the the
um pollution all of the things that are
issues which helped you create the
nonprofit that you have with scuba
divers here in New Hampshire assist or
hurt
I believe that it would help
um all the way around I think it would
help the fishermen get their gear back
if they have you know if they haven't
been able to get that with grapples
um then they would be able to get it
back we have to adhere to a very strict
um set of rules uh we have to deal with
the local politicians the local
officials the the Marine Patrol we have
to report everything that we do and it
isn't an easy thing to do what we do
costs a lot of money and if you could
get fishermen and divers to work
together
I think that you could see a big benefit
representative page
so I think a a critical difference I'm
seeing here between Maine and New
Hampshire is that it sounds from your
description like you had your community
on board
um
could you speak and that's clearly not
the case here from what we're seeing
from people who are coming up coming to
testify can you speak a little bit about
what the process was of bringing the
lobstering community on board with this
and and how that happened how you how
how you were able to collaborate to have
this be a team effort certainly uh so I
knew a lot of the fishermen on the coast
of Maine uh from my time there and uh I
was able to speak to them about what was
going on and before we got in the water
to the point where we could be seen as
molesting their gear we worked with them
on Shore and we talked about the benefit
that this would bring and uh and quite
honestly they all uh
I'm going to say we have just about 100
of them on board we had a couple of them
that said oh you know I don't want you
out there I don't want you touching my
gear and as soon as I told them that we
brought in 20 of fishable gear they were
on board and uh I I hope that that could
be the case here
yeah um so we we have
um we work with the the students who are
living in the fishing communities we're
bringing added benefit to them by
teaching them how to scuba dive uh
teaching them cold water survival
training drill conductor courses we're
teaching them a lot about uh how to be
safe and how to be responsible on the
ocean and the fishermen appreciate that
any other questions
I've got one myself
um if you would
be able to answer we have heard
testimony uh in the last uh date of
public hearing and and seeing some stuff
since that uh from Massachusetts Rhode
Island and Maine they they have uh an
estimate that about 10 of the lobster
gear is lost each year
and that's a significant amount of traps
every year
we were told by the fishermen here in
New Hampshire that they don't lose 10
percent because they're very expensive
and that if they do lose the traps they
end up on Route 1 when a storm comes
because the storm action brings them up
and washes them ashore
um
could you
speak to
the percentages that that you're seeing
do you think it's 10 in Maine as we're
getting reported
um and what would the difference be
between the numbers that we're seeing uh
of New Hampshire versus Maine or being
reported in Boothbay Harbor I would say
yes there are 10 of the traps
um being lost and the reason I say that
is Boothbay Harbor is a tourist spot
it's uh there's a lot of boat traffic
there are a lot of um
whale watching and turo uh
eco-terrorists kind of uh events going
on so the traps in Boothbay Harbor
um their High number and I would say yes
that is correct offshore uh I don't
think that they're losing that many and
um and I think when when the 10 percent
is given
they should look at whether or not those
are retired traps that have been brought
ashore and are are you know still in the
yards and and wharves of the fishermen
that could be part of the ten percent
and um we're still trying to figure that
out
and I have one follow-up you did mention
briefly that you recover traps that are
still usable
I imagine you're able to get those back
to the individual lobsterman to whom
they belong and that that's a big
savings for them because of how
expensive we've heard the traps are
that's right um that's part of why
they've agreed to work with you that's
correct all right I wanted to clarify
that thank you
uh yes Mr Vice chair
thank you Mr chair and just one quick
follow-up on that as you said there's a
lot of boat traffic in the area
that's not
Lobster fisherman boat traffic that's
public boat traffic that's probably
cutting off the lines or causing some
other damage not to the fault of the
lobsterman all of the above there are
fishermen there are whale watch type
boats and then there are pleasure boats
that are typically big and powerful and
go through and if if the Tide's running
at all and the buoys are under they
okay any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and if you've got written anything to
make sure that you get it to the group
um and you mentioned pictures I if you
only have one set you can give them to
the clerk and they'll make copies for
everyone to look at later okay and the
clerk is
right here thank you thank you very much
thank you for your time today
uh I will now call Eric Anderson
from the nhcfa
who opposes the bill and is asking for
uh good morning Mr chairman and
committee
um my name is Eric Anderson I'm here
representing the concerns and opposition
to House Bill 442 as president of New
Hampshire commercial Fisherman's
Association I have been here when this
bill was originally proposed and um and
also through the course of the last five
years where this bill has come to the
attention of this Committee in its never
passed uh legislation
um the amended version is no better than
a previous submissions and broken into
components
um it describes
um is not well written and confusing in
its text in its meeting
um and I'll go into some of the uh
details of that allowing um to take
Lobsters by means of diming is just not
good policy no matter how described from
a variety of reasons and you will hear
that type of testimony from fishermen
and New Hampshire Fish and Game
biologists and New Hampshire Fish and
Game enforcement today the policy for
harvesting this resource is over a
hundred years in standing
and has been and has proven successful
in maintaining this resource it has been
presented here this legislation has been
presented here because of its allowance
in Massachusetts
much to the regret of Massachusetts
Department of Marine Resources
and any proposal like this in the state
of Maine would not see the light of day
as far as taking Boxes by means of
diving
I've in previous presentation I've I've
submitted to you that it's been proven
that a
um that this that the lobster trap
fishery sustains this resource
um through the course of seven years
that a lobster the juvenile Lobster will
grow and mature until it take until it's
of a reasonable size
um to harvest that Lobster has been in
that that Lobster has been in through
that trap thousands of times it knows a
trap as well as you know why are you
sitting here it knows how to get into
the Trap it knows how to feed in the
Trap it knows how to get out of the Trap
and the only reason that we catch
lobsters is because we Haul them when
the lobsters they're in there and so it
has every means to maneuver through that
trap with seven years of experience
until it gets to legal length
um
some of the confusing and not well
written language is represented in pages
in lines on page one lines 30 through 32
where it states
um with regards to a designated area
it says all areas outside the zones
shall be restricted to harvesting of
lobsters by those with the scuba diver
recreational Lobster license I don't
know what that means
in one sense it says that there'll be a
zone for diving for lobsters and then in
the net and then in this sentence
vertebrate him it says that harvesting a
lobsters will take place out harvesting
by little officers by means the diving
will take place outside those zones
areas
so even an amended version this this
piece of legislation just is not well
written and it's confusing and out of
respect to this committee I think any
piece of legislation that comes before
you ought to be well written understood
and and and not questioned in a way that
it's written
um
Lobster diving zones must be it says in
that in this legislation Lobster diving
zones must have parking and
accessibility to um to waters for divers
I don't believe the executive director
has the authority to designate these
areas under his under those requirements
I think that is legislatively he doesn't
that the executive it states the
executive director must designate those
zones and he doesn't have the authority
to do that from a shoreline perspective
all licensed Revenue shall be credited
to the derelict fishing gear and Coastal
cleanup fund this is the wrong place
even if this is considered we are
opposed to this but if it's a place for
Revenue to go this is the wrong place
for it to go the administrative and
manpower to perform the requirements of
this legislation is prohibitively costly
and as much as we are opposed to it it
would be wiser to have any license fees
go to the operating costs of New
Hampshire Fish and Game this is not a
this is this is a very expensive piece
of legislation as far as operating costs
for the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department and that should be considered
in your con that should be taken into
consideration for your for this
particular bill
um the reporting requirements described
in the legislation do not currently
exist and would and would require
considerable time and effort to
construct either it's either from the
diving perspective or where they're
going to report that they'd take
lobsters or from the from the fact of of
of of of of trapping tracking where
Lobster gear is presently located
um it's it just doesn't make sense it
just doesn't make sense and it was I
think this is written outside the
context of of of the the knowledge of
how how the fishery operates
um
this legislation states that the
executive director would have to
sanction and approve dive shops and
instructors by means of certification
and compliance this would require a
whole new set of circumstances not
currently with the New Hampshire Fish
and Game system
so what this is a it's a complicated you
know and it would take some time to do
it
um
starting on page three lines 34 and
onward this legislation
has requirements for lofts to trap
location tracking
and it's not well understood why this
legislation is trying to dictate a
policy of requirements already practiced
by a lobster industry and when Lobster
gear and when Lobster gear gets detached
from the mark from its boys
um
every particular effort by the
lobsterman to recover that gear is made
this gear is not cheap
in the last couple of years it has
doubled in quadrupled in the cost of a
lobster trap so the loss of a trap
um
the industry goes to a great extents for
recovery
uh
when it's when it's detached
um
I think that you should described by the
previous speaker almost makes sound
horrendous that this is a tremendous
problem within the fishery in the state
of New Hampshire I just don't believe
that so
um we don't have you know uh
the the type of Fisheries along the
shore it's not in a it's not an area
like Moon Bay Harbor where there's a lot
of other boat traffic that that you know
contributes to the lawsuit here
um it is a different it is a different
fishery and I think that an oncoming
speaker will will describe that it's not
the same fishery in New Hampshire as it
is in Maine
um
and we would go for it we can go further
in many of the aspects of this
legislation that are confusing it just
don't make complete sense but these
seven or eight points that we've
described would raise concern within
this committee to question its Merit we
hope you listen closely to New Hampshire
Fish and Game and their concerns is they
are the ones who ultimately have to
administer enforce this legislation
and and again and you know outside of
these comments it's just a editorial
opinion I think when a piece of
legislation comes in front of this
committee and the value of this
committee and what it has to consider it
should be well written it should be not
confusing it shouldn't raise concern to
questions over its Merit and and I don't
think this this piece of legislation is
does it does that I I can read through
it I could go on for a considerable
amount of time over some of the
intricacies that are described in this
legislation and some of the questions
that it raises that it should raise with
you and and it's not well described and
it's confusing and it's just not well
written
even in in even in its amended form and
so I would hope that you would consider
to um oppose or itl this piece of
legislation for further considerations
and then um I appreciate your time thank
you thank you sir for your testimony
today are there any questions
so I I have a question about the zones
as well um
I heard testimony that
um divers don't have underwater GPS it
doesn't work or they don't have that or
or whatever so if if you're a diver how
would and you don't have that GPS
equipment available to you or it doesn't
work how how would you know if you're
still within the zone
that's a very good question it's it's
described in here that you know there
should be a Zone but it you know in in
the actual you know anytime you you make
a Zone you make a line that on one side
of the line you're good on the other
side of the line you're bad the dive I
don't think there's a reasonable there's
a reasonable way to measure that system
in the water and that divers would not
have the ability to recognize where they
exactly are if they're outside or inside
the zone or
um whether there's any other
um whether there's anything else going
on within their activity you know in
regards to taking lobsters and I've said
it in previous legislation but I mean
what was described by the previous
speaker it creates it creates two user
groups in the water at the same time
it's the same place
and it creates a safety issue that is
beyond comprehension
I think it would be tragic if you were
to pass the legislation and create a
system where these two user groups
are operating at the same time and I'll
tell you one thing oh you know a boat or
getting tangled up in the gear uh you
know a diver getting tangled up in gear
or anything else that could potentially
um develop in this situation I think it
would be a tragic travesty to pass
legislation that would that would that
would allow this to take place
um and and I don't think it's an issue
in New Hampshire that you should
consider at this particular time
thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
the chair now recognizes Bobby nudd
New Hampshire fishermen
was requested eight minutes and opposes
uh Mr chairman members of this committee
before I start my testimony uh I'd like
to give a quick rebuttal to the
gentleman from Newcastle Maine
and
I understand I understand the project I
understand the project that happened uh
that's going on and has happened
down in Massachusetts Bay and the
concept uh is very admirable and I I
actually agree with the concept
and secondly the main trap fishery is a
single trapped fishery in the near shore
Waters
The Fishery in New Hampshire which by
the way has the smallest Coast in
America
we don't have the loss of gear that you
will have in the single trap
Refrigeration
that's pushed by rebuttal to his
statements Mr chairman members of this
committee
my name is Bobby nugg I have spent the
last 30 years representing the state's
law obser Fishery
I have sat at the table through the
introduction debate and implementation
of almost every law which governs
today's Lobster Fishery
I am currently the New Hampshire
representative on the Atlantic states uh
on the Atlantic lives reduction team and
I am a member of the Atlantic Station
marine fisheries commission Lobster
Advisory Board
the Trap fishery is under constant
scrutiny by the scientific Community
regulators and every major environmental
organization
every aspect of this fishery including
trap bycatch and abandoned Alaska Air
has and is still being examined under a
microscope
the Trap fishery is accepted throughout
the world as the only resource
sustainable and environmentally friendly
method of taking lobsters
the commercial officer men have been
stewards of this resource and the
environment for 100 years or better
to try to portray them or their methods
of fishing is something different does a
during the hearing on the original bill
I listened to testimony that Lobster men
lose 10 percent of their traps every
year
I believe reference to that figure comes
from the fact that lobstermen are given
the opportunity to purchase 10
additional trap tags above their trap
allocation
apparently to some that has become
synonymous the traps lost every year
that is not true that 10 percent was an
arbitrary figure based mostly on helping
the states and fishermen deal with a new
and burdensome regulation how do I know
that I sat at the table
if a commercial lobsterman lost 10
percent of its traps every year he would
not be in business
extra trap tags were allowed for trap
tags lost from the traps
it periodic switching out of gear as
well as an occasional trap loss
[Music]
now to the proposes proposed amendment
itself
as with the first version of this bill I
am still concerned about page two y9
small G
we're a legal Lobster a legal legal
diving Lobster was described
my concern is the admission of RSA 211
which all relate to the preservation of
The Brood stock
when those Provisions were debated at
the Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission there was testimony from a
Rhode Island dive organization opposing
those Provisions because their dive
parties were only interested in Trophy
lobsters
which would not be available under those
provisions
everything I'm talking about today
uh I'll probably mute points if this
bill is adopted as written
I reference page one line 31 sentence
beginning with all
if that sentence stands as written there
will be no commercial harvesting of
next page three line 35 in reference to
trap log keeping
I am a federally permitted Lobster
dealer and hold a state wholesaler's
license
I evaporated a state of New Hampshire
trade name since 1983.
I buy and sell lobsters under this
capacity I have no knowledge to comply
with this provision
as a lobsterman I find it
find a usefulness of this type of log
questionable I know where my gear is
years ago someone asked my wife if I
hold trapped in the fog and how I found
them
people asked and she said here's a
thousand traps pick a fog he knows where
everyone everyone is he can't remember
his own name
I see this provisioned as an invasion
into my personal fishing knowledge and
nothing more than harassment of a
fishery
page eight live page four line eight
somebody authorized by owner
years ago it was common practice and it
was allowed for a lobsterman
to authorize
someone other than himself to 10 years
traps
with the Advent of trap caps and effort
control this practice was eliminated
because it provided a loophole and a
temptation to circumvent circumvent
effort regulations
in April of this year I will as a member
of the lobster Advisory Board we asked
to make recommendations on a resiliency
addendum there's a Lobster management
plan that may result in increased size
limits and trap modifications I
guarantee part of my consideration will
be looking at effort
page four line 15. as a member of the
lives will take reduction team I have
significant problems with this entire
paragraph
although many of you have been led to
believe that the lobster industry need
to do nothing in relation to Wales until
2028 it is not true
and even if the new implementation date
and even the new implementation date is
now in jeopardy with the introduction in
the United States House of
Representatives of a bill to repeal that
date
the Consolidated appropriate
Appropriations act also provides for and
I quote development and implementation
and with under this mandate Noah has
stated that they will work and I quote
diligently to develop and expand the use
of on-demand fishing and other gear
modifications
there are fishermen in other states and
federal waters currently experimenting
using gear without attached buoys
starting in the spring of summer this
year is anticipated that there will be
New Hampshire fishermen also involved
this paragraph is a complete
contradiction to the development of
phishing methods that may allow the New
Hampshire logs and fishery to coexist in
the face of a challenging situation
now I want you to know that I hold the
legislation of this state and highest
regard and I have the greatest respect
for those who give their time here
but to me the part of this bill that
deals with lobsters is a vindictive
attack on the only commercial fishery
left in the state
all because lots of fishing will believe
the taken of lobsters by active rather
than passive message is inappropriate
it's an attempt to demonize a fishery
the Geary users and the way it's
conducted when in fact this fishery has
always been in the Forefront when it
comes to sustainability and environment
if I have offended anybody with my
statements I offer my sincere apologies
but when it comes to crafting
legislation involving lobsters it's best
left to those who understand and are
aware of the implications and the
ramifications those proposed laws may
have the largest scheme of things
and I thank you very much for listening
to me
thank you for your testimony today are
there any questions
Vice chair
thank you Mr chair would you take one
question
excuse me I'm sorry no right here thank
you
go ahead you had mentioned early in your
testimony the difference between how
Maine
sets traps as single traps versus trawl
in New Hampshire could you just explain
the difference of the two and what
you're talking about for those who don't
know yes main state of Maine the state
of Maine uh the inshore Fishery uh is
basically a single trap Fishery
uh which means one trap one buoy
uh
New Hampshire
has
or
I won't say forever but for
50 years has been a trial Fishery where
we fish
a number of a number of traps with Bowie
on each end
the difference is that with a single
buoy
boat traffic
chafing
Mother Nature or whatever uh
can easily detach a single buoy from the
trap then the Trap is no longer is lost
it's a trawl fishery which we have in
this state we have a say 10 trap for all
we have a bouillon each end we lose one
buoy we still have the ten traps because
we have the other buoy one buoy chafes
off right we still have the other one
right if both boys
chafe off we have 10 traps with one
ground line that is easily retrievable
you can't do that with a single trap
which is what Maine's fishery is so to
compare the two I'm not don't get me
wrong the concept the concept of
cleaning up the ocean
is not something I have a problem with
so
but but the two Fisheries can't be
compared right and this
that's a concept what he's talking about
I'm talking about the builders before
you today and to build it before you
today is is does not do what
the concept is thank you thank you
thank you
um
the chair will now call Weldon Bosworth
representing himself and he supports the
uh thank you chairman splane members of
I am from Guilford New Hampshire I
submitted a testimony on this particular
Bill last year and again this year in uh
in January and I just had a couple of
points I'd like to make as an amendment
to the Maye testimony
I wanted just first of all to remind
those on the committee who may have not
been here before my experience I've been
a certified diver for almost 64 years
I've as a youngster used to take
Lobsters by hand and Massachusetts where
it was permitted I have a doctorate in
Marine Biology with an emphasis on
benthic ecology which is a study of the
animals and plants live in and on the
bottom
and I make these comments from that
standpoint again my Consulting career
was on evaluating impacts of human
activities on species in the ocean
a couple of uh
I guess issues have risen to the top
here of a reason why people oppose this
bill the first was the damage to the
lobsters and the bottom uh
basically in fact a couple of the people
from Fish and Game maintain that based
on their experience this is a
significant issue
while it may be their experience or the
experience of others they've talked to I
think in no way should this be
considered to be a generalized point
uh I think anybody that is a experienced
diver that has hunted lobsters realizes
what an earlier speaker say you don't go
turning over rocks you hunt them and
it's a subtle Sport with basically like
hunting deer or Birds Upland game that
kind of thing you wait till you see them
lobsters in their native state during
the day when the divers are there
generally would have their antennae or
their head sticking out of a crevice and
you basically grab that the thorax
behind that and bring them out you don't
rip off their claws I mean the first
time diver may do that once and find on
its uh a very ineffective way to get uh
to get lobsters as a benchmark I have
taken lobsters crabs scallops and even
Flounder with my bare hands and not made
any impact to the ocean bottom the other
point I'd like to make is what I
consider to be the inequity of looking
at this rulemaking as hey you're guilty
until a proven innocent in other words
there's this doubt here that if this
bill goes into effect or the rules
associated with this bill that goes into
effect all hell is going to break loose
and diver's going to be out there
poaching traps I can assure you this is
not going to happen like with any group
of people there may be met Bad actors we
have only a hundred permits given by
this bill contemplated uh they're going
to be registered with their names and
everything on the boys so you'll know
who's there and I just don't think
that's going to be a major issue to try
to enforce in fact uh fish and game has
a lot more difficult problems enforce
and I gave it as an example in my
testimony the number of hunting licenses
and fishing licenses which total over
000 which the state it has to enforce
with I think it's less than 40
conservation officers now which is
ridiculous it should be twice that at
least but
to try to put into a perspective from a
statistical or probabilistic standpoint
catching that one diver that might catch
might poach a trap to the violations
that could take place on any of these uh
licenses that are already issued is uh I
mean it pales by comparison
the idea that was brought up by the uh
speaker who or the representative that
introduced this bill that we are
basically uh favoring in some instances
the non-resident because non-residents
can hunt fish and take Lobster
uh from our Waters and you you're
denying a group of divers a small group
of divers from taking some of their uh
one of our public trust resources I
think is inequitable and basically
inconsistent with New Hampshire's New
Hampshire Fish and games mission
I wanted to speak just a little bit
about uh sustainability which is brought
up by a couple of speakers
sustainability has many faces and if you
look at it from a holistic standpoint
the lobstermen that use the bait in our
Gulf of Maine waters are basically
taking other fish other species and
using them to bathe their lobster traps
the typical Maiden uh in the Gulf of
Maine used to be the herring in fact the
lobsterman took over as it reported over
70 percent of the Herring stocks in the
Gulf of Maine
the Herring stocks are now depressed so
they're switching to menhaden and I
guess a couple other species to bait
their traps so that's one element of
sustainability that one has to look at
to look at the overall sustainability
quotient of lobster fishing the other is
these uh ghost traps that we've been
talking about uh
given that some of the traps here are
trawl traps in New Hampshire there's
others that are single traps basically
once a trap is lost it continues to fish
and studies that have been done show the
escape from the traps more the mortality
from fish
caught in the traps can range from 10 to
40 percent those studies were done in
Maine and down around the cape
as a
in a trap as the time goes on other
animals actually wander into the Trap
and they may die they provide bait for
the next sequence of animals that come
into the Trap if a trap stays down over
a winter you have a lot of things
growing on it not just
sponges and hydroids but also seaweed
and so forth that basically causes the
vents not to work as they properly
should so here's another element of
sustainability I wouldn't base I would
guess based on looking at the various
data that the amount of lobsters
projected to get
uh by the Harvest by divers is far less
than those that are going to die in any
trap
and as far as the reading of this bill I
read this uh page one article 31 is that
the scuba divers are restricted from
going outside the zone so I think that's
the way it's supposed to be
any questions
thank you for your testimony
um we have been willing to take
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
the chair will call Damon Frampton
representing the industry and opposing
good morning and thank you for
being here and listening to us
just uh I just have a couple minutes
here my name is Damon Frampton I live in
Newcastle New Hampshire
thank you for hearing my testimony
against and never will be in favor of
scuba diving free diving or skin diving
for taking or harvesting of lobsters in
the state of New Hampshire
to me House Bill 442 is back for
discussion not because it's a great
popular idea but because in its sixth
attempt there is obviously concerns and
reservations
a little background about myself I've
been a scuba diver since age 12.
in a lobster commercial Lobster in the
state of New Hampshire since 1984.
a lot of us here today in New Hampshire
Fish and Game biologists Commissioners
conservation officers commercial and
recreational Optimum New Hampshire
Marine advisory boards and retired
commercial housemen do not support House
Bill 442 and have testified repeatedly
against diving for any form of lobsters
in New Hampshire all these individuals
and entities have several hundred years
combined and knowledge behind them with
experience on the working Waterfront and
are familiar with the dangers of diving
in the open and respect what the state
of New Hampshire has done to protect
this Lobster resource we continue to
hear repeatedly how divers can Harvest
lobsters safely being on the commercial
Fleet Safety being in the commercial
Fleet Safety and resource of the biggest
concerns for myself
House Bill 442 is divers listed as Skin
diving scuba diving and free diving
those are three kinds of diving which
means three more ways for law
enforcement must attempt to monitor plus
three more ways to create problems in
dangers in the open ocean to the divers
and to boaters
I also struggle with how this proposed
bill will impact the resource the state
of New Hampshire and its lastmen should
be proud of how they've grown nurtured
and protected this precious resource the
five 100 600 and 1200 Lobster Pot
fishery have with no question farm this
resource within with conservation
marriages and millions of pounds of food
a New Hampshire lobster Fisheries we
entice lobsters into our lobster traps
where we bait and ensure they are fed
and have the energy to reproduce support
juveniles the broad stock and completing
the quote-unquote circle of life
any form of diving to harvest Lobster is
not a full circle if you will diving for
lobsters is taken only
is to take only fishery with no
possibility of conservation education
and feeding of juveniles and broadstart
lobsters taken by diving will
be enticed by ripped or tickled out of
their whole or borrow without a full
belly
and no possibility of Escape no free
will to come and go as they do in
lobster traps
in New Hampshire we have a lobster trap
fishery and it works
every New Hampshire resident has the
right to obtain this lot to participate
in this Lobster resource my opinion is
the Trap fishery is the best thing for
its residents the resorts and its users
and I've to end this and in the past uh
I think the sixth time or maybe more
that I've been here I've offered and
will continue to offer anyone who shows
interest and wants to learn about
lobstering in New Hampshire to call or
come aboard my boat the fishing vessel
Vivian May to learn and observe the
beauty of our ocean and resources
thank you
thank you thanks for taking my question
clarify for me what you said because I
don't know what you're talking about
uh Lobster's taken by diving will be
enticed or ripped or tickled excuse me
enticed by being ripped or tickled out
of their hole that I understand or
burrow without a full belly and no
possibility of Escape what is the point
of them not having a full belly can you
explain that to me yeah they just uh
they go into the traps to feed to eat
and uh lobsters are always looking for
food yeah so
uh they may be sitting on a rock waiting
for food
waiting for something to swim by a crab
or whatever and it hasn't happened where
lobster trap they can they go
YouTube it lobsters go in and out of
those things all day long and feed
follow up
thank you
um you said that you had um
uh invited representatives to come
aboard have any Representatives actually
taking you up on that yet uh I think
last year I had and I don't have my
emails with me but okay one replied and
said they were interested but my offer
stands all right are both big enough I
can take one person one day all right
and could I do a follow-up
um what would be the way to contact you
uh on this uh
I answer emails I do not answer cell
any other questions
thanks
uh chair will now call The Honorable
Dennis Abbott
five to ten minutes requested
representing himself and opposes the
bill
good morning Mr chairman
and good morning to all all the
committee members
um
my name is Dennis Abbott
I reside in Newmarket
and I have for the last 80 82 years I'm
not a lobster Fisher
but I do have an abiding industry in
their well-being
and the health of and sustainability of
their industry
this is a bad Bill
I'll repeat it it's a bad Bill
I'm reminded years ago when I was a
member of
of the legislature
that Neil Kirk who served here for many
many years always said
tell the committee or the house what
you're going to say and where you stand
at the beginning tell them in the middle
and tell them at the end
and he was quite a good legislature and
he sat on the other side of the aisle
I think that this bill is deserving
coming from this committee
you might ask how I arrive at this
conclusion but first let me give you
some background of where I come from
regarding Lobster management
I'm a former seven term legislator
I served 10 years on this committee
I was the chairman of this committee for
two terms
have also served for the past 27 years
as the legislative commissioner a
legislative proxy commissioner to the
Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission which you've heard mentioned
numerous times this morning during
testimony
the Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission is a regulator of Lobster
management and many other Coastal
species a lot of the laws that you see
that have been promulgated by the fish
and game department originate with the
Atlantic State's marine fisheries
Commission
the Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission was established in 1942
to be a Cooperative group amongst the 15
Atlantic Coastal States from Maine to
Florida
there are three Commissioners from each
state
I being one I am the permanent proxy for
Senator Waters
Sheree Patterson who's in the back of
the room is the second one and Doug
leader of the Marine Division in Durham
is the third commissioner we vote as a
body a state has one vote
for the three of us
we meet four times a year in Washington
D.C we have numerous State hearings and
we're going to have a hearing tomorrow
evening on of all things lobsters
and one of the issues I think Bobby nudd
mentioned or someone maybe it was Eric
Anderson that mentioned that we're going
to be looking at possibly increasing the
gauge size because contrary to what the
person who introduced this amendment
said the lobsterf
the lobster fishery is not in As Good
Health as some of us would like to
believe according to the scientists
they're finding that settlement meaning
juvenile Lobster counts are down in the
state of Maine and therefore the state
of Maine is
was the principal mover in having us
look at regulations regarding lobsters
and one of the easiest things to do is
change the minimum size but sitting over
in the corner of previous fellow that
testified
my good friend would tell you that we
shouldn't shouldn't be doing that and we
probably probably shouldn't and before I
go into some of my written testimony I'd
like to take issue with some of the
things that were said and I would thank
Bobby nudd for his enlightened testimony
though I do disagree with him that Maine
has a single line Fishery
at present a big movement because of the
whale issue is and we're dealing with
that also is that they're trying to
minimize the amount of fishing lines
buoy lines in the water
they have two usually they fish in
trials with two on each end which
minimizes the chances of losing the
trolls if you break one buoy off you
still have the other one allow you to
retrieve the rest of the trawl and as
Bobby Ned said I know that they know
where every one of their trolls is set
through the year
and we also our organization
through
knowers insistence we just
passed another law for the lobsterman
where they're going to have to have
trackers on their boat so that we can
tell they can tell
where those people are fishing in real
time
and those are going to be installed I
think in the next year
some of the other things that were
mentioned number of traps I sponsored
that bill for harmony traps could be
fished in the state of New Hampshire
another thing before I get into my
written testimony was gentleman said
that there's a loss of up to 10 percent
of traps Bobby Nutt counted that by
saying yes
we passed the law in Atlantic states
that we issue extra trap tags for
whatever reason damage traps or whatever
you have to put a different tag on
because of the tag that you use you
can't break it and put it onto another
trap so that's another reason why
they're issued extra traps and think
about it for a minute
the state of Maine has 6 000 licensed
lobstermen
the majority of them are allowed to fish
800 traps do the math and you come up
with two to three million traps do you
think they're losing 200 000 traps a
year I don't think so
I'll bet you that Mike Flanagan will
tell you that he probably didn't lose
one trap last year because he's a good
lobsterman as are all the gentlemen
behind us or good lobster fishermen and
again as I stated at the very beginning
I'm here because I'm here to protect
those lobstermen those lobstermen are
trying to make a living
and me on the other side of the coin at
times are involved in enacting
regulations
not regulations necessarily but what we
do at Atlantic states is if we pass
an amendment or an addendum store
management plan the state has to comply
with it if they don't comply with it
they are subject to being
held to account by the federal
government
so anyway let me see what more I can say
and I'd like to say
as I read this bill I didn't have to go
by the first sentence before I knew this
was a bad Bill
because I feel that unlike individuals
legally fishing for lobsters divers have
and will not make any investment in
promoting the health and well-being of
the industry
these people sitting in the back here
are running what I would consider a
modified
aquaculture industry
do you have any idea of how much food
that they are feeding to the lobsters I
heard Eric Anderson say that the lobster
goes in and out of a trap maybe a
thousand times in his lifetime and they
they're waiting for these lobsters to
reach the minimum size of three and a
quarter inches before they can take them
so probably or for instance in the state
of Maine alone they caught 12 million
pounds of menhaven to feed lobsters
New Hampshire caught about 5 million
pounds of Manhattan to feed lobsters
That's not including the
2000 tons of Herring that are caught to
feed lobsters every fish in the ocean is
feeding off another fish or or creature
out there
we have to remember I think at the end
of the day
that these lobstermen are individual
business owners and they're trying to
make a living
and they have an investment
a lifelong investment in the
sustainability of the lobster industry
they
abide by the laws they're as I said
they're feeding the lobsters and also
another thing that hasn't been mentioned
that the lobstermen do is we have a
v-notch program where egg-bearing
females the lobsters carry their eggs on
the bottom of their tail for quite a
length of time they have to put a
v-notch in those lobsters and place them
and they can't can't take them home so
again their their investment is
substantial and I think that we should
be very aware of the things that we do
that affect their livelihood I'm not
going to get into the second part of
this non-germanum amendment talking
about
keeping track of what's going on on the
bottom and whatever basically we don't
need divers catching lobsters
I compare
some of us might say that lobstering is
a natural is a resource public resource
and it is but for you people 75 percent
of you maybe more are really divorced
from the Seacoast but how would you
think if you were living up in Colebrook
or in Ossipee or wherever and you were
nurturing a forest and someone comes in
and says I want to start cutting down
some trees and take them home with me
are you planting a garden
and someone after all the work that
you've done wants to come in
and pick your crop
these people
as I've seen in the past few years are
having more difficulties a greater
difficulties in making a living
one of our fellow Commissioners from the
state of Maine
said that he's diversifying out of the
lobster industry lifelong fishermen he's
growing kelp now
in the winter Lobster and used to catch
northern shrimp you know the shrimp you
used to buy on the roadside or whatever
you won't find them now because we
Atlantic states have declared a
moratorium for the past nine years or so
so again they're being buffeted by so
many things the right whale issue is
such a big thing
you know that's going to cause the
ropeless fishing uh possibility of
seasonal
fishing
I've probably taken more of your time
than I should but however I'd ask you
this is a non-partisan issue
the issue here today is the well-being
of the lobster industry
so I ask you to respect the lobsterman
and the long-standing tradition of
lobster fishing
show your respect for the independent
businessmen that they are go and shake
their calloused hands that have worked
on the water all these years
do not change the method of taking do
not add another nail to that coffin
and I
thank you for your attention
and I'll take any any questions that you
have and if you ask me questions I could
be here all all day but I welcome your
questions thank you thank you hopefully
we're not here all day
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman
um thank you for taking my question so
you made a statement that you deny that
10 of traps are lost uh to the Sea could
you then tell me where the thousands
upon thousands of traps that are
discovered underwater where they come
from
I will grant you that a lot of traps do
end up in the bottom of the ocean for
various reasons I think that here in New
Hampshire they have a coastal cleanup to
pick up lobster traps that are
that are lost through the course of a
winter hurricanes and the like again
that Lobster fisherman that uh I
mentioned he's from
fishes out of Portland Harbor I think
that last year he was part of a program
where they went out looking for lobster
traps and I think he pulled up a ball of
traps that was so big they actually had
to get a crane to lift them all out of
the water but again if you look if Maine
is fishing two million traps do you
think that they're losing 200 000 traps
a year and multiplying that over a
period of 10 years do you think that
it's probably you know two million traps
on the bottom there is a lot of traps
and you know that's an issue but that's
entirely separate from divers wanting to
go diving which is supposed to be this
subject of the bill
the lobstermen don't want to lose traps
one of the
testifiers told you that a trap sitting
on the bottom of the water represents a
hundred and fifty dollars
a lot of them fished 10 trap trawls in
some areas maybe more maybe less
depending on situations do you think
they're interested in losing fifteen
hundred dollars they grapple for the
traps if they know where their traps are
they I would guess that each of these
Lobster probably has a grapple hook on
their boat and they can do their best to
recover it because they don't want to
thank you uh yes representative Brown
can you clarify sorry thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
can you clarify what you said about
um some locating devices that a law that
has requiring locating devices and what
the cost of that is and just give it yes
that was a recent addendum to one of our
management plans it's in the process of
being enacted right now
it's going to be funded by NOAA
Fisheries to initially
Supply The
Trackers to the boats
and they can look
they can look that ties into your cell
phone through the internet and they can
actually track
where your boat's going and in time they
can see that your boat is stationary for
a length of time and they can
see that you're hauling traps the reason
for that partial in large part is to
show where the fishing activity is
there's an awful lot of fishing activity
offshore and this is intended again it's
only those that are holding Federal
permits that are going to be required to
have trackers aboard and I will say
initially and I voted against having
them
have trackers on their boat because I
felt it was an infringement on their
privacy
and whatever and whatever I didn't think
that we should be doing it because those
trackers are working all the time that
you can't shut them off so if even if
they're in state waters state waters
being within three miles of the shore
federal waters are three miles out
but everywhere they're going you know
big brother can be tracking them so
whatever
and again as I said that's being paid
for by the federal government at this
follow up thank you
so to be clear that's for tracking
vessel location not Lobster Pot location
no but you can deduce from that if a
boat is stationary in one location you
know moving from one area transiting an
area you can see they're not fishing
there but that will also you know have
the benefit of showing where lobster
fishing is occurring and where lobsters
lobsters are
but there are is another gentleman said
there are so so many rules that they
have to comply with and a further Point
let me make one last point if I may
back in 1997 when I started on this
committee
there was a fellow again the committee
room was set up a bit differently and in
the back corner here sat a fellow from
London not Londonderry Litchfield I
believe his name was Bill bushy
and he was in a wheelchair he'd been in
a wheelchair since the Korean War
he was a republican on the other side of
the aisle for me but I viewed him as a
mentor when I had questions about what
was going on here I went to Bill
and bill says always be careful of
granting the fish and game department
rule-making Authority because once you
grant them rule-making Authority they
then have the ability to make rules
after you made a law so he was always
suspicious I'm not suspicious
individually of the colonel back here or
Cherie Patterson but you don't know who
they're responsible to they're
responsible to 11 other politicians the
Commissioners Fish and Game
Commissioners and appointed director so
be careful of granting rule making
Authority
yes representative Khan you can
ask your question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
you mentioned that a lobster you know
juvenile Lobster goes in and out of the
trap a thousand times you know
many many times and our fishermens are
feeding them and those
feeds are not cheap those are expensive
you know feeds you know those fishes
that you put on the Trap the food
and you saying that our fishermen are
giving them food and everything making
you know helping them grow and somebody
else is going to come to catch them are
you saying that can you elaborate a
little bit more
elaborate on that
well it's very simple
a lobsterman is feeding those those
Lobster a lob cement is feeding those
lobsters with principally men Hayden and
and that's what they're eating and
that's what they're
they're living off
I would say because of the proliferation
of number of traps out there in bait
provided that's contributing to the
health of the resource
if that answers your question thank you
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you Mr chairman it's a
pleasure to come back to the committee
that I still consider part of my life it
the chair will now call Michael
egludry
egloy okay representing himself supports
the bill
does have written testimony uh if you'd
like to provide our clerk with a copy of
that either before or after you're done
wow uh
okay well yeah my name is Michael glodi
I'm a resident of New Hampshire
um since the age of one
um I was born a mass doesn't make me bad
I am the owner and the operator of a
flooring showroom in hooks it Loose
floor coverings I'm here in support of
house bill 422.
um
proposing a recreational license
recreational license for New Hampshire
resident scuba divers to take Lobsters
by hand and to free animals trapped in
abandoned lobster traps
before I go through this I just want to
say first and foremost that the
education and the history that I've
heard here this morning is just it's
just blows my mind it's amazing I and I
respect these lobstermen these guys work
harder than me maybe I don't know I work
hard I'm in the construction industry so
you know we all work hard and
I envy them I I would I would really
love to you know get involved with that
but I grew up in construction but I'm
going to get back to the uh business at
hand
um you know trying to describe scuba
diving in words will always fall short
of the actual experience
it is very physically demanding and even
more mentally challenging than most
would imagine until they get in the
water
most who try don't follow through with
this as a regular activity diving isn't
for everybody it's an there are inherent
risks and potential hazards they're far
too numerous to talk about
and they could take any of our lives at
any time if you were to ask even the
experienced divers many will quickly
tell you that diving in New Hampshire
sucks all right the water's cold the
visibility is awful the variables are
numerous and dangerous and most of the
time unexpected quite honestly it can be
very scary at times for even the
experienced diver waves currents depths
visibility equipment companions markers
watercraft all of these things need to
be at the front of your mind and only
then may you consider the task at hand
whether it be recovery repair
photography scalloping spear fishing the
list goes on my personal history under
the water began around 2004 after a
certification course I got for a
birthday gift I found being in the
underwater environment was more than
exhilarating the fish the Rocks the
caves the silence it was a spiritual
awakening for me to A Whole New World I
loved it and I wanted to keep seeing
more I've always loved nature Hunting
Fishing anything to do with conserving
and protecting our Treasures on this
Coast
it was a spirit it was it's
I'm sorry but it blows my mind that it's
against the law to free an entrapped
creature from certain death in an
abandoned trap and there are piles of
them and thousands in this video and
or that it's against the law or even to
even identify the Lost gear for the men
to put a buoyah on it you know I the
videos and the testimony today you know
that are available demonstrate just a
small fraction a small small fraction of
the Carnage that's been ignored for
decades yes there there's certain
retrieval programs but they'll never get
it all you can if you're not seeing it
you're not going to drag you can't the
hooks don't have eyes
you know what hard per hardworking tax
paying Sportsman or woman wouldn't want
to help their fellows recover the tools
of their trade their livelihoods while
improving the natural environment we're
there to improve we're not there to you
know the opposition of this bill can
only be based on unwarranted paranoia we
want to help
we aren't here looking to be Good
Samaritans we don't we're not looking
for a pat on the back we love diving we
love the ocean
but seeing the amounts of entangled
traps is beyond disturbing these traps
can and will perpetually kill why well
obviously a trap that is not retrievable
its lobsters die guess what the dead
Lobster has just become a
self-perpetuating bait the owner of the
gear can't retrieve it then they are in
turn hurt financially the environmental
damage continues to compound that's why
we're here not just because we would
like to take a few lobsters we're
talking about a hundred permits you know
so small and you know a small amount of
divers don't need traps to harvest by
hand safely
divers won't drag traps across the
bottom or pull rocks across the bottom
drivers won't bring smaller egg-bearing
lapses for the surface stressing them
out and exposing them as an easy target
to other Predators on their way down
divers can save lives of unintended
bycatch divers can Mark gear divers can
improve the habitat that was canned and
want to work with fishermen this is a
good build this isn't a bad Bill
we have way too much time money training
and respect for the environment we love
and want to conserve
we don't want to steal your lobsters
help us help you
and that's pretty much all I've got any
questions thank you sir he's open to
the chair calls representative Jason
janvren
representing Rockingham 40 from Seabrook
thank you Mr chairman again I'm Jason
German Rockingham 40 super Hampton
I've actually represented Seabrook
it's my third term representative
Seabrook I've represented District
20. District
37 and now District 40 with all the
re-configuring of all the districts
um
I I do want to say that my history in
the town of Seabrook
my family's been there since before it
was a town they've been here since
before it was the province of New
Hampshire
so my family came here from the Isle of
Jersey via Nova Scotia as fishermen
and so I signed on as a co-sponsor of
the original underlying bill for a
couple reasons I'll get to that in a few
moments but it may be very interesting
to you that a co-sponsor of the original
bill is against the amendment and now
against the bill underlying
I'll explain why one of the things that
a state representative as you know has
the ability to do is to be named to a
commission by the speaker of the house
so the Speaker of the House in 2017 2019
appointed me to the Coastal Marine
natural resources and environment
commission I'll say that one more time
Coastal Marine natural resources and
environment Commission
I was very happy to see that this term I
have been taken two years off from the
House of Representatives that I have
been reappointed to that same Commission
I'm going to list you who the members
are of that commission Senator Bill
Gannon Senator Waters
Tracy Emerick of Hampton House member
Judy Spang House member Michael Edgar of
Hampton
House member JD Bernardi Southampton me
Jason jamron
from representing sieberg in Hampton
we also have representation from New
Hampshire Des
cription game
the aquaculture industry
UNH Cooperative expansion the New
Hampshire nature carbon Conservancy
environmental science from and unh
I think you've already heard from Eric
Anderson who's the representative of the
commercial fisherman on the commission
we have dread everybody dreads them
and the aquaculture industry has a
second representative on that commission
it's very interesting to note that this
legislation was not recommended
and was not given to you by that
commission that commission is put in
place to track where things are I can
tell you two years ago three years ago
now
that we had this conversation about this
bill and and the amendment that you're
seeing here about tracking down Lost
Lobster pots
um and and all those sorts of things we
met with the industry they do have the
cleanup days they have a cleanup fund
and they're correct they don't want to
lose their their fishing gear out there
so
this bill again is unnecessary
we've already the question was asked by
representative goalie you know how how
are they going to geolocate where that
trap is under the under the water they
can't
they can't
um
if if the people that are scuba divers
want to help the fishing industry
go into business
hire yourselves out to those Lobster
fishermen
and go out and find their traps
so that they can go pick them up
maybe they'll pay you with lobsters
there's no need for this bill or the
amendment
any questions
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative taking my question
representative as you all know or some
of them some of us do not know that the
Seabrook Beach
is owned by Seabrook taxpayers not the
state of New Hampshire
and do you think that passing this bill
is gonna clash with the town planning
board
not only the Seabrook but all the
coastal towns and cities that they're
going to have new zoning
for shops for diving you know shops or
diving industry because they're good
people they're they're good industry I
have nothing against them
but they can team up and they can have
new Zoning for this that they're not you
know towns and cities it's not going to
be allowing
well I will say this that uh presently
into my knowledge in Hampton between
Hampton Hampton Falls which doesn't have
Beach but does have uh waterfront on the
Harbor and Seabrook there are only two
dive shops actually I take that back one
uh the second one we're not a business
the first one had a fire and relocated
to the second business so there's only
one dive shop
between Hampton and Seabrook so I I
don't see this as a booming industry
and just for the record I'm actually
Paddy certified and and I actually scuba
dive with boy scouts because I was a sea
Scout okay okay so I'm not against
divers I'm damn well not against our
fishermen so thank you
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
the chair called Sheree Patterson from
Fish and Game
who has written testimony she can assume
get to the clerk
good afternoon good afternoon Mr chair
and members of the committee I am Sheree
Patterson
representing uh the New Hampshire Vision
game department
uh just as a note that the Fish and Game
Commission has voted to oppose this bill
in each version that we have been
presented with
as I have testified in the first hearing
of this bill on January 30th then you
may have received
the written testimony
the lobster commercial fishing industry
is the largest fishing industry in New
Hampshire it brings in a revenue of 34
million
dollars annually
for the
little over 300 commercial Harvesters
that we have licensed
if you look at the economy as a whole it
likely is three to four times that
amount or roughly
102 to 136 million dollars
as you've heard today this is a highly
regular regulated Fishery
it's regulated through
collaborative efforts of the states that
have American lobster
and Fisheries that land American lobster
and it this collaborative effort is as
you've heard Dennis say through the
Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission and there is Lobster
management plan that is constantly being
this current version of House Bill 442
changes nothing that was emphasized
during an earlier testimony for the four
um
to indicate a few on this particular
version
we we do have
concerns about some unfunded mandates
we have concerns about how the wording
can be both nebulous and scope and
confusing
on the intent
and right now the department does not
have resources to conduct unfunded
mandates and we do see also
um
with these mandates some unenforceable
issues
I would like to go over some of these
concerns in this current bill and I have
line by line
comments not line by line I should say
there are some lines that I have
comments on for example line one I mean
I'm sorry page one line
28 there's a phrase there that says
unless a lower industry-wide limit is
established
we're not sure what this means
um who would initiate a lower
industry-wide limit would it be the
Atlantic states marine fisheries
Commission
that pretty much just
works with commercial industry not a
recreational industry
um
is would it be New Hampshire Vision game
outside of a fishery management plan
would it be the legislature is confusing
how or and what the intent is for that
phrase
under page one lines 31 and 32 all areas
outside the zones shall be restricted to
harvesting of lobsters by those with a
scuba diver recreational Lobster
this is confusing language as you've
already heard
it can mean
that
um
Lobster Harvesters that are fishing with
traps can't fish
or it could mean that the scuba divers
can only fish within established diving
zones it's just confusing nice to have
some clarity on that
page two lines three and four area
accessible for both parking and water
access and which may already be
frequented by divers actively harvesting
crab and other legal shellfish
well New Hampshire doesn't have any
authority over parking and water access
outside of Fish and Game properties so
does this mean that if a municipality
state parks
private property access
if those parameters change
does fish and game need to change those
zones and how quickly can that happen
or would fish and game
as well as fish and game doesn't really
know
areas that are frequented by divers
these are just assumptions that are
drafted in here that are pretty nebulous
page two lines six and seven no person
holding the scuba diving recreational
Lobster license Shell at any time take
any Lobsters by any method except by
hand again a little confusing does this
mean that an individual that holds a
recreational and Commercial Lobster
license to fish by traps that if they
also hold this Scuba diving license they
can no longer
utilize traps they have to harvest by
hand it's just wording is awkward in in
several places throughout this bill
page two lines 9 10 and 11 all lobsters
taken under a scuba diver recreational
Lobster license shall be of legal size
as provisioned by
couple rsas measured immediately upon
capture on the seafloor before surfacing
you've heard from the lobster industry
how they have rules and regulations
based on sustainability of the lobster
population
so it doesn't just pertain to the size
of a lobster it also pertains to they
can't
um
Harvest egg bearing lobsters
if there's a bee Notch they can't
Harvest that particular Lobster either
there's these aspects that the lobster
fishing industry abide by that are
missing in this in this bill
page two section J line 17 through 24.
where
the director is
going to be supplying or is requesting
to supply a report
to the legislature fishing game is
indicating the impossibility have
already indicated the possibility of
enforcement of many aspects of lobster
Harvest by diving listing complaints as
possible of course but not sure what
violations issue will say about the
illegal activity that law enforcement
cannot enforce or effectively
investigate
page 2 line 27 New Hampshire guide to
e-regulation
we're not sure what that is is this the
page two line 33 34 and 35
section d
registering details of lobster take by
online Lobster registration system so in
other words building a reporting system
for divers this is an unfunded mandate
again being unposed on
the fish and game budget during a period
of budgetary constraints
there is a reporting system that is
built for
the lobster Harvesters
um
but it would be costly to modify that
system to include diving
on page three line three lobstering
equipment there is no definition in this
for lobstering equipment to guide any
rule making or enforcement this term is
in other parts throughout the bill also
page three line five and six educational
course regarding permissible scuba
diving Lobster activities this is
another unfanded unfounded
mandate being imposed on the fish and
game budget and we are not aware of any
federal funds that would be available to
help with establishing educational
courses
page three line 25 Lobster Indus
lobstering industry there's no
definition for lobstering industry what
how can we Define that without any guide
for within this for rulemaking and
enforcement
page 3 section 2
e lines 27 through 31 reporting format
and criteria for divers harvesting
Lobster this is another un founded
mandate
what is the importance of reporting only
sex and weight of each Lobster taken
within 12 hours of the of the Harvest
using electronic means current reporting
criteria for the lobster industry
um
does not have these constraints
as well as just having those two sex in
weight as a data element
would would not
provide us with any science to assess
catch and effort information in regards
to
improving or managing the lobster
population
page three and four
RSA
21132a lines 34-37 on page three in
lines two through six on page four
this is the lobster track location
tracking and probably one of the most
disturbing for me
the four rsas listed here
are non-resident and Resident commercial
saltwater licenses
and resident and non-resident wholesale
licenses
this does not
address
any of the lobster licensees that fish
in state waters those four licenses
are for
Harvest that occurs in federal waters
and allowed to be landed in New
Hampshire
there is no license in this section that
requires a person
licensed Lobster by trap in New
Hampshire to track location of traps
essentially those that Harvest Lobster
in federal waters are subjected to this
proposed location tracking New Hampshire
would not be able to enact enforce this
in federal waters without complementary
federal regulations
there's nothing in here that would be
tracking any Lobster gear that would be
there is no definition for normal
fishing methods what what is normal
there's also a phrase in there that says
shell the lobster industry shall make a
good faith effort to retrieve traps
how is that defined
violations of this section this would
require Fish and Game verification that
there was detached gear for longer than
page four lines eight and nine for traps
that are attached and retrievable no
person except the owner
someone authorized by the owner Etc
what does this mean and who decides
whether they are attached and
retrievable you've heard already about
on demand or buoyless gear that is
likely to be
enacted into the lobster fishing
industry in
years to come
and there is currently testing being
conducted in other states and will be
conducted in New Hampshire with
also this may leave someone that is
unlicensed to be able to pull gear in on
a consistent basis
this can allow people in a particular
license category whether it be 100 600
or 1200 trap license category to be able
to fish more traps by allowing somebody
they authorize to pull traps
this becomes a loophole
we already have a process for extreme
situations that require letters letters
of authorization to be possessed and
notifications made
for example if there is a lobster
Harvester that has passed away and he
has gear out in the water
we have set up letters of authorization
to allow other members of the fishing
industry to go out and pull his gear
we already have those set up
page four lines 20 and 21 under no
circumstance May the animals released be
kept
how would this be enforceable
in conclusion we want to continue to
emphasize that people concurrently
Harvest lobsters recreationally in New
Hampshire
buy the five trap Lobster license and
this is open to any New Hampshire
resident
currently
there is no non-resident
um
that are licensed in the state of New
Hampshire it's residents only that are
licensed to fish in state waters
this is because it's not that we don't
have that license category
but there is an exception within the
rules regulations to indicate that if
the non-residence state
does not allow for the same category of
Licensing
then they cannot get a non-resident
license
and there's no States from New Jersey up
to Maine that have the same licensing
categories
so you'll find that for commercial
licensees there will be no non-residents
it would be residents only
same with recreational there is no
non-resident this is for New Hampshire
it allows a uniform enforcement
opportunity when it comes to harvesting
lobsters using traps while trying to
provide balance access to the resource
the state's advisory committee on marine
fisheries also oppose continues to
oppose this legislation Unfortunately
they are unable to come today to testify
I thank you for the opportunity to
testify today and the department urges
the committee to vote House Bill 442 in
expedient to legislate and if you have
any questions I would be happy to answer
thank you for your testimony today are
there any questions representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and I appreciate you
and all the men and women works for your
department you do you do a tremendous
job for all of us thank you
my question two-part question one is
all the testimony you heard
for last couple of hours do you have any
desire
disagreement on those testimony that do
you disagree with any of those
testimonies that we had from
opposing this bill
on the fishing industry
um
the last man should speak for themselves
you know I could speak to
um fisheries management aspects of
lobster harvesting and some
enforceability we have law enforcement
here to provide testimony also if you
have more
specific enforcement questions
Mr chairman follow-up
follow-up
so uh one of this testimony was uh
I didn't know that you know it's
eye-opening for me that the juvenile
Lobster goes in and out many many times
and the number was thousands of times in
and out of trap and we know that those
traps brings thousands of pounds of food
under you know the ocean floor
do you think that that is that that is
the fact that you know that those
juveniles gets bigger because of those
food and the other food
it's well understood that it's
essentially an agriculture system there
the the animals are being fed until they
get to a particular size that allows
seeing none thank you for your testimony
the chair calls Graham Birch
representing himself uh asked for 10
minutes
if you want to hand that at the end
so Mr chairman members of committee my
name is Graham Butch I'm a 26-year
resident of Hollis New Hampshire
and my professional life I'm a product
manager for a boston-based software
company and in my leisure time I'm a
part-time scuba instructor for aquatic
Specialties in Merrimack New Hampshire
where I enjoy introducing people of all
ages to the sport of scuba diving and
teaching them to safely enjoy and
respect our Coastal environments please
don't be intimidated by the large number
of pages I've just given you all I don't
intend to go through them all most of it
is just for your reference
um
so I'm here today as a member of the New
Hampshire diving Community to express my
support for Bill 442 I believe that this
bill is a very reasonable proposal I
think it respects the environment of the
ocean the wildlife of the ocean and
those that make their living from the
ocean
you were gracious enough to hear my
testimony at a hearing of this bill on
January 31st of this year so I'm not
going to bore you with a repeat of the
same testimony but you will find that
testimony attached at the very back of
the packet that I just gave you for your
reference
just before I start the three points I'd
like to make I just want to address one
point that was made earlier about uh you
know how scuba divers might be
um hunting for Lobsters by turning over
rocks
you've got to be there to see it
and number one you can't just go turning
over rocks while you're diving you're
neutrally buoyant you have no purchase
to be able to do that number two if you
were to try and do that you're lifting
The Rock
lobsters underwater don't move like they
do in Market Basket
they don't crawl they they swim so that
big lobster tail that you enjoy eating
is a muscle that allows the lobster to
propel itself backwards incredibly
quickly you have zero chance as a diver
of catching a lobster on the move like
that so now you've got one hand lifting
up a rock allegedly right the lobs has
gone off and you're trying to catch this
thing that's going at tremendous speed
one-handed I'm sorry it's ludicrous
and and on many counts so what I would
like to say is uh I'd like to give the
opportunity for anybody on a committee
or any of Fish and Game who are
certified divers I'd love to take you
out and show you how it's done
unfortunately I can't
because I'm in New Hampshire
and it would be illegal
but if you would like to see it done I'm
sure I could hook you up with one of my
Massachusetts bodies and uh they'd be
happy to take you out and show you
exactly how it's done and uh how very
little disturbance there is to the
underwater environment which we respect
deeply
so on to my uh my testimony I have three
points
Point number one uh there was a question
in the last hearing about which Atlantic
states allow diving for lobsters so I
spent an inordinate amount of time
trying to research this on the internet
and I can tell you for sure
Massachusetts Rhode Island Connecticut
New York New Jersey Delaware Maryland
Virginia and then you know what it kind
of Peters off a little bit into states
that really don't care that much because
they don't seem to have that many
lobsters as you get further south until
you hit Florida
but they don't have real lobsters down
in the last hearing I heard
one com one conservation officer said
that it was his understanding that
Massachusetts would end their scuba
diving program if given the chance like
this is just so contrary to what I'm
hearing from other Massachusetts divers
that I I want to do some research I call
it the Massachusetts experience I know
when not Massachusetts right but when
you're looking for
who else is doing this and what's the
experience like then I think we do well
to just at least
learn from the state next door
so as part of your package
um I I came across this document this is
a from May of 2019 it's from the
Massachusetts division of marine
fisheries it's a technical report TR 69.
it appears to me
based on
the citations on pages 14 and 15. it
appears to be a very well thought out
deeply researched document I'm not an
expert I'm a scuba diver so I'm just
reading what the experts have to say and
this this paper this paper just it says
nothing at all about the commercial
Lobster industry
this is all about
the recreational Lobster industry so you
know say it up front absolutely nothing
at all against the lobstermen that make
their living out of fishing for lobsters
fully support that industry and this
paper does not denigrate that industry
at all it's purely recreational
what it does is it provides us insight
into the recreational trap
practice and also recreational diving so
so it pretty much in fact maybe I could
I highlighted a few
pieces for you
um again we don't have to go through
them all today but if you can turn your
in the the abstract at the top
I highlighted something just uh you know
part way down there
annual trap loss in the recreational
fishery is estimated at 26 percent of
traps fished now these guys don't lose
that much I fully believe that there's a
reason that recreational Ops have been
losing so much because they ain't that
and the paper goes on to describe
numerous circumstances as to you know
um
at the top of the introduction the
accumulation of accidentally lost and
intentionally abandoned fishing gear and
Marine Waters is a global problem coming
across many gear types of Fisheries
reading down modern traps constructed
from durable material fish longer but
when lost can persist in the environment
and cause damage to the sea floor
habitats for many years and there's a
number of citations
the next paragraph contrary to popular
belief and I think we've heard the
popular belief today contrary to popular
belief derelict traps often continue to
catch Target and non-target species well
after the original bird source is gone
trapped organisms die and cyclically
self-bit The Traps again a number of
citations in a phenomenon known as ghost
fishing which can result in local
opinion
this is taken from a well-researched
document
so I'll uh spare you the misery of
reading you the other pieces that I've
highlighted
um but I'm sure you can draw your own
conclusions by just at least paying
attention to the the parts that I
so I think this uh this this paper
refutes the notion that recreational
trout fishing is preferred over hand
it quantifies the impact of diving for
lobsters on the industry we'll get into
that in a moment it understands the need
to take action to clear erosions of
ghost traps and it does not raise any
significant issues at all related to
in the last hearing it was asserted and
in this hearing was asserted the only
method for non-commercial taken of
lobster traps of lobster should be by
trap and yet this entire 22-page
document is dedicated to the negative
environmental impact of that activity
the environmental impact of lost
recreational lobster traps is so serious
that the Massachusetts division of
marine fishery has launched an
educational campaign to combat the
I believe it's highlighted at the column
two the top paragraph beginning in 2017
the DMF published a series of videos
designed to Foster responsible
recreational lobstering and provide
participants with a more comprehensive
understanding of the fishery videos are
available on the DMF website
there's nine videos up there they're
great videos I watched every one of them
but it was such a problem that they had
to take action and go and produce a
series of videos and educational
programs
funnily enough in those videos you'll
actually see in the I think it's the
first or the second one you'll see them
retrieving traps that are ghost traps
lost traps and in some cases they're
pulling animals out of the traps
foreign
how can the opponents of this bill
possibly propose a recreational Trap
Fishing as an alternative to Simply
taking a lobster
by diving
when the environmental impacts of
recreational Trap Fishing are so well
documented
such a suggestion is environmentally
unconscionable
the suggestion is frankly ludicrous and
secondly and I think this is probably my
biggest Point here we've just got to
talk about the elephant in a room this
this report helps us to understand
the negligible impact of divers on the
lobster population no diver wants to
steal a family's living
and if if that's in your mind we've got
so let's try and do some numbers
so the bill says you know not let not
less than four weeks so let's assume we
give an eight week season or eight
Saturdays or eight Sundays of diving
assume the diver has a great day for
each of those days and he backs his
limit of three lobsters
so three lobsters defined in line 28.
This is an annual catch of 24 lobsters
assume per diver assume that on any one
day
fifty percent of the divers with a
license are hunting and the all 100
licenses are issued as defined in line
14.
which is actually 50 is actually High
when you compare it to figure three on
page six which suggests about 30 percent
of recreational licenses are actually
fished
so the total catch of all divers is
about 1200 lobsters in a year
average Lobster weight 1.46 pounds again
that is not my supposition I'm just
getting that out of the working numbers
so that gives us an annual catch of
1752 pounds so we pull the annual
commercial catch from the NOAA website
for New Hampshire of
5708 942 pounds do the numbers it's
0.03 percent
of the commercial catch
I try to give you a graphic and through
the magic of excel you have a chart
as part of your package
the Red Lobster is a commercially caught
Lobster the black Lobster on our
optimistic estimates
is what the diver would catch it's
rounding errors it's insignificant
I honestly don't know why we're having
this conversation without first having
visited the facts to see what the real
so another data point
if we look at uh again from tr69 table 3
on page seven gives us some really nice
numbers it gives us the numbers of
permits that were reporting a catch the
number of traps fished the hours of
diving and the pounds of lobster caught
hours of diving 4403 pounds of lobster
18809 caught in those hours that gives
you 1.3 pounds per hour average size of
lobster 1.4 pounds it means that a
diver's catch in about
0.9 lobsters per hour
let's round it up call it one
80 cubic foot cylinder of air lasts
between 40 minutes and one hour it's
about one Lobster a dive
two tanks per day
two lobsters
so
original assumption that led to this
chart said three lobsters a day that was
an overestimate
based on actual numbers
coming out of a state that does allow
diving for lobsters
we can use another data point divers
caught 18
809 pounds of lobsters divided by 140 so
by 1.46 that gives us 12 803 lobsters
divide the number by the number of
permits
12 lobsters
12 lobsters in here my estimate that led
to this was 24 lobsters the numbers
coming out of Massachusetts suggest it's
probably nearer 12. so you could double
the number of Reds
another data point take it from the main
lobster industry
2021 Lobster harvest in man according to
NOAA 10 million 230 440 pounds divide
that by 1.46 it gives you 75 75 million
75 million 500 301 lobsters
divide it by the estimated number of
traps been fished which is 2800 and
sorry two million eight hundred and
sixty one thousand
gives you 216 lobsters per trap per year
previously we estimated the annual catch
per diver at about 24 per year
to 26 24.
ocean cleanup
an important aspect of this bill is the
initiative to form a positive working
relationship between the recreational
dive community and Commercial fishermen
to improve our marine environment by
removing harmful lost fishing gear from
our Coastal Waters I myself on a dive
swam past
numerous love supports abandoned Lobster
pots or lost or ghost
but one sticks out in particular I put a
picture in your packet there this uh
this little beauty
kind of fish that probably only his
mother would love it's a ugly looking
beast but it's what we get to work with
you don't have it we don't have angel
fish and butterfly fish in in New
Hampshire but they come in great all
kinds of colors they come from this kind
of deep russet color all through oranges
and yellows but I'm swimming past the
Trap
the Trap is covered with Marine debris
like it's it's got algae growing all
over it it's been down there a long time
it has a single piece of rope dangling
off the end that's four feet long and
turn around and swim away
I can't touch it
I couldn't open the Trap
and let him go even though it's plain to
anybody with common sense that that trap
so in conclusion um thank you very much
for listening to my testimony and I urge
vote common sense and vote Yes for the
Bill thank you
I'll take any questions thank you for
your testimony he's willing to take
questions are there any questions
representative Harvey thank you Mr
chairman
um thank you for taking my question
um I'm not a numbers person
um and you threw a lot of them out there
at me so
um I I'm going to turn your
numbers around i s i see where you're
trying to make the point that this this
one little black Lobster down here
doesn't affect anything over here I I
get that that was the message that you
were giving rounding hours okay all
right so but my question I'm going to
turn it around these people are all
doing this mostly for a living that
they're This Is How They sustain
themselves and their family okay so
why do you want to take that one Lobster
you're saying you're going to get one
Lobster per dive I'm sorry that's not
even enough for my dinner so why is it
that you want to do this I get these
people they this is their living why are
you asking for since it's so Minnesota
that's a fantastic question it's just a
fun thing yeah it's a great question I'm
really glad you asked because if we
think of this as Lobster harvesting
you're thinking of it from the wrong
I'll tell you what my wife would be
seeing none thank you very much for your
and the chair will now call Colonel
Kevin Jordan from New Hampshire Fish and
Game our last speaker of the day
and I'm going to let the committee know
that since we have an exec session
scheduled for one o'clock
my intent is to let us eat lunch so we
will open the exact session and recess
it when we hit hit the one o'clock time
to a Time known so we'll give each other
uh until probably two to eat and then
come back and do our exec session and
that's my intent so we can discuss it if
needed but I think the the ranking
member here is is also interested in
eating something and taking a break
um
they didn't bring any Lobster that I
know of
um
and if the divers brought it it would
and with that Colonel Jordan it is up
all up for you now all right good uh
good morning or actually good afternoon
Mr chairman of members of the committee
appreciate your patience I know it's
been a very long process for this
um
I I am going to raise concerns one one
thing that by 33 years I get more and
more irritated as I spend more time here
of people that come up here and tell you
how to do law enforcement that have
never spent one minute of their life
doing it I'm here to tell you
I would encourage those folks to join us
when you try to prove a case because it
is very different from what you're being
told
and I would ask you uh to not take my
word for that but to pick up a law book
and read it very carefully on laws that
have been established for over 80 years
and read them line by line and you will
see very clearly they're written in a
sometimes confusing way but of but a
very distinct way the elements are clear
the things that you need to prove are
very uh they jump should jump off the
page to you and those are those are laws
that work
this amendment represents anything but
that this amendment confuses me more
than any amendment I have reviewed in
the 10 years I have been coming to the
legislature it has got more doubling
back switching over and and it's
frightening to me and I'll tell you why
it's frightening to me I don't Lobster
fish I I love all of these guys behind
me because I work with them and I'd ask
you to keep one very important factor in
mind they are not recreating they're
trying to feed their families they're
taking these lobsters home to feed their
lives their children support their boats
and support the New Hampshire economy
that's a little different than deer
hunting because I enjoy deer hunting
it's a little different than than
trapping because I enjoy the sport of
trapping they're making their living on
it and I think it requires us all of us
including me and my officers and and I
brought a young redhead back there that
will that will substantiate that I'm
very strict on how we do deal with these
people for that very reason they they
believe very strongly in what they do
they're not perfect we make violations
for lobster fishermen we don't do it a
lot but we have done it I think I think
they have really cleaned their act up
over the last two decades
um but but please consider that when you
look at this this is a little more than
I want to get a lobster you know we we
currently have
uh in your own researcher found this out
we sold 531 Lobster commercial Lobster
license along our 18-mile Coastline and
that 18 miles is a stretch it's a very
short Coastline so we had 531 licenses
that means that at any given time the
possibility exists that we can have 21
000 lobster traps in that 18 miles now
if you're going to sit here and tell me
that in that 18 miles we're going to put
divers down here and there's not going
to be a conflict I got news for you
there is going to be a conflict there
has to be it's too short of a distance I
I compared it talking to my lieutenant
back there I compared it to Interstate
95 Interstate 95 in the state of New
Hampshire is about 16 miles long this
would be the same as if we took those
Troopers and we blindfolded them and we
said go out on 95 and enforce the law
because they can't see to enforce it no
more than I can see to enforce the
diving as I've explained to you in that
last bill and then and then I want them
to provide me stats on how how they did
that enforcement those stats aren't
going to be very valuable because there
aren't going to be many of them you
cannot enforce half of what's in this
bill you just can't do it and and I've
got some Cherie went through it line by
line which I which I really appreciated
there are some extra ones though that I
just wanted to bring your attention to
some that I think are are significant so
the first one right out of the gate on
page one out of eight paragraph eight
and nine they're inserting this new
paragraph lobster crab scuba diving
recreational Lobster license and by the
way scuba diving recreational Lobster
licenses called four different things
all through this bill it's a commercial
diving license it's a recreational
diving license it's a diving license so
that's going to create confusion in any
courtroom that you go into we've got to
refer to this stuff exactly the same
every time time that we do that in order
to prove a case they want to amend 2118
by inserting this after paragraph 2A
that's the wrong location that needs to
be inserted under paragraph three in
that law following criteria shall apply
to the issuance of lobster and crab
licenses by the department I've got
three pages of that kind of stuff
where this has been misplaced or
misworded or misquoted basically or or
ineffective in the law
another one we talk about in here is
um
uh making dive tanks or putting numbers
I do appreciate the effort here that
this license shall consist of letters
and numbers which a person engage in
scuba diving shall affix to his or her
diving tanks and regulation die flag in
a contrasting color making it readily
visible to a conservation officer that
should read plainly visible because
that's defined in law not readily
visible and it should read law
enforcement instead of a conservation
officer so a defense attorney can come
into a courtroom for those of you that
have never been into a courtroom and he
can say to me can you define Colonel
readily visible
now I'm going to ask you can you define
that
I was asked once to tell you tell a
defense attorney how what alcohol smell
like
and my answer to him was can you tell me
what spaghetti smells like
but that's what these cases come down to
that's the kind of language that you
have to be careful of you have to use
verbage and phrases that are already
defined in our law and there's a lot of
them plainly visible law enforcement
officer those are things that have to be
included and and this bill has none of
that it has absolutely none of that
it refers to statues that don't pertain
to the action that they're discussing it
it it's just a mess from start to finish
um
setting a season by rule for the
executive director creating an online uh
registration uh method which we've no
we've never done we've never registered
lobsters we registered deer we register
there we've never registered Lobster to
create an online system we're currently
working on an oh HIV we've been working
on it for two years to create an online
ability to register your ohrv through
your computer as you're coming up the
highway rather than going to an agent
we're at a cost of close to thirty
thousand dollars
who's going to fund that where's that
money going to come from I we don't have
that kind of money and we're in a
predicament now where that law passed
they mandated that we do it and the
governor has is run on a platform that
we we can't charge any new fees so those
Hits come into the department and I
don't I shouldn't have to tell this
committee because a lot of you have been
here a long time these unfunded mandates
are killing us rabies go out and collect
rabies and investigate rabies we're not
going to give you a nickel for it but
transport them all over the state and
get them tested and and make sure you do
that with the 35 guys that you got
covering from Pittsburgh to
Massachusetts oh and then if you get a
call for a fallen hiker I want you to
run up there Scurry up there and pick
those Folks up at 50 000 and drag them
down and we're not going to give you any
money for that either because you guys
know some of you have helped me try to
get that money out of the general fund
it's not going to happen
and we can't do it anymore frankly I I
think a better way to do this let's try
something new let's try to come up with
a way this bill is trying to address a
couple of different things
is trying to give diaper divers an
opportunity to enjoy our resources I
would submit to you they have that
opportunity now they can get a five pot
license they're not prohibited from
Catching lobsters the method is
prohibited just like they can hunt deer
but you can't do it with a cannon you
can do it with with guns that are
permitted but everybody gets the ability
to hunt deer everybody can take a
lobster too it's just we limit how they
do it for for some of these reasons so
let's take an opportunity if we're
really looking to address two issues
which I think this bill is Ghost traps
which I'm a little shaky on the science
on that I'm looking at at information
that was received from the biologist in
Rhode Island who by the way is a
recreational diver I'm sure he didn't
share that with anyone but he is a
recreational diver
and then the one for Mass the division
chief for mass and with all due respect
to both of those States they don't
really have other than than Mass has
done a little bit of work they don't
have a lot of information about this
they're all starting to look at it
they're all which is great I think New
Hampshire should start to look at it and
I heard today for the first time that
maybe we are why don't we do that first
why don't we look at this first number
one this is just a suggestion number two
come up with this thing that is in this
amendment that talks about I don't even
know what it is the regulatory guide
program the educational program I'm
assuming so that we don't have issues
let's create that and and most
importantly
let's come up with a way to pay for it
before we spend it let's come up with a
way that we can guarantee the money's
going to be available to be used for all
the right things which is what we're
trying to do here because if there's no
money for it we can't do it we can't do
it the other thing that I want to stress
to you again we talked to all the law
enforcement agencies in these states
that allow it I talked to the deputy
chief Kurt Blanchett in Rhode Island I
talked to the Marine Patrol colonel in
Maine and by the way the state of Maine
will never see this happen and that's
the largest Coastline on the New England
coast why do you suppose that is if it's
such a great idea why is it Maine
jumping on board I think there's a
reason for that frankly Rhode Island and
Mass both have done it both their law
enforcement agencies told me very
similar things the major at Rhode Island
said when when this first came to be the
lobster populations on the shoreline of
Rhode Island were much greater than they
are today he blames the warming of our
oceans uh and that the fact that the
majority of their lobsters are now
caught three miles off the coastline so
that reduced the ability to catch to
catch lobsters diving so he thinks the
numbers of the complaints went down
because of that he said in its Heyday
when the lobsters were popular along the
coastline like they are currently in New
Hampshire
um that there were numerous conflicts
the Massachusetts Coastal officer who
enforces this and again these are the
guys that are going to get the calls for
the complaints these are the guys that
are going to do the enforcement they're
not biologists or division heads they're
the people like me they're the people
out in the field like like this
Lieutenant behind me that are going to
be dealing with this you know this will
shock you but when they approach divers
they dump the lobsters
um he can't see what happened I've seen
that happen in New Hampshire the one one
time I made a lobster diving case a guy
came to the surface with a garbage bag
full of them I don't know how he did it
I don't know if he got him out of traps
but he had a garbage bag full of bugs
and as we approached him he dumped those
luckily he was closer to Shore and we
could scrounge those up because if you
don't have the evidence you don't have a
case obviously
so they they tell us that that happens
and and the one thing the coastal
officer said in Massachusetts
was that over half of the checks that he
does with lobster diving results in some
sort of a violation so it's not uncommon
to have that happen what is also a
challenge for him would be the same
challenge in New Hampshire is you can't
prove it folks you can put a paragraph
in here a well thought out paragraph and
it was the divers will measure these
lobsters before they reach the surface
you're going to see that
no I'm not going to either and there's
nobody in this uniform that's going to
see that so that's not worth the Papers
written because you can't enforce that
unless unless you're going to give me
extra people and dive tanks we got dive
tanks but unless I put dive tanks on
them and put them down that's not worth
the ink that was used to write it
because you can't enforce it how do I
prove in a courtroom that he measured
those lobsters or that he didn't measure
those lobsters you cannot do that don't
do that to us please don't give me a law
that we can enforce it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous and then I would strongly
suggest that we separate these issues I
think there is some absolute interest on
both the divers and the lobster
fishermen from what I heard sitting here
today and certainly I know there is for
my agency to do some research on ghost
gear and find more effective ways to
clear it from our oceans I think we're
all in agreement to that I think there's
money to be made for our divers if it's
done correctly I think that possibility
exists and I and I think that's
something that we should think about but
separate that from the diving piece of
it don't don't couple it with diving in
order to get the diving piece passed
that's what I feel like happened here
those are two separate issues take up
diving and discuss the issues take up
ghost gear and figure out a way to do
that and and make it enforceable for all
of us so that what you give me in
writing I'll make sure that we follow
that's all I'm asking you to do
that's all I have
thank you Colonel do we have any
Colonel George
um so
it may surprise you when I was reading
this that I thought I was reading two
different bills because one is about
lobsters and one is about
traps and I had to go back to the
beginning to see no it's the same bill
um so I'm assuming that
neither of these sponsors was in touch
with
um fish and game as this bill was being
crafted to maybe alleviate some of the
questions that you have brought forth
well I don't want to say they weren't in
touch with fishing game I could tell you
uh clearly no one was in touch with
anyone from law enforcement no one was
in touch with us I don't I think there
was some contact very early on with our
marine biologists but I but I don't
certainly we weren't contact not the and
I don't I don't please don't take that
to mean that I'm an expert I don't need
to be contacted I'm just saying let's
write one that we can enforce that's the
you give me good laws 90 of the time
let's not let's not spoil that with this
and people behind me that don't do law
enforcement tell you this is a good law
it's because they don't do law
enforcement because it's not a good law
it's a mess
so so maybe some contact might have
helped follow up
thank you no I'm done
thank you any further questions
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Colonel for your
yes sir let me ask you a question you
said you have a list of items in front
of you uh on could you supply that to
the committee please we can do that I'd
rather go back and clean it up but I'll
get it to you some of the issues that we
had yes we have uh 30
23 excuse me 23 different points that
we're questioning yes okay with
different verbiage and and things like
that thank you Eric and this is for the
chair can we take a five minute recess
before we go uh out of the public
hearing before we go into the exact
session
we're going to be going into the exact
session and recessing it to a Time
certain so that we can eat lunch and
then we'll be back so you'll have plenty
of time to do anything thank you
are there any other questions
representative Brown thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question yes sir
it's not quite related to what you were
talking about
is Fish and Game responsible for
managing where divers can be and have
you had any complaints about
interactions between lobstermen and
recreational diving regardless of what
of of this spill online yes so I well
the first question is we don't really
regulate where they can be I can't think
of any place that we do that because
currently in New Hampshire they can go
wherever they want but in regards to
that in this bill that creates some
concerns that that representative Khan
brings up is it you know if you're going
to set up zones the most difficult job
we have is boundaries on zones that's
why we use highways uh I don't know how
you do it in the ocean you'd have to
you'd have to have some sort of a
landmark for them to understand are you
going to create criminals out of some of
them and the other problem that you're
going to get into is you're going to get
into conflicts with some of the towns
and cities that own the property where
this would begin we don't have authority
there I do get complaints from
lobsterman not a lot of them but I do
get complaints from losterman that
divers uh are hitting our traps we used
to get it a lot more than we get now the
one advantage I have with that sir is
that's something I can enforce because I
can find out where his traps are and I
can set up surveillance on those traps
or set up surveillance in that area and
check divers if I see them if I have a
diver who's randomly hitting traps the
only way I'm going to know that is if
I'm under the water with him with tanks
that's the that's the concern I and I
don't you know I want to I'm always
concerned about the people that attend
these hearings because these are not
criminals behind me you've got divers
here who I can tell you from listening
to them are very qualified and very good
individuals those are not the
individuals I'm going to be chasing just
like these lobstermen on those people
don't come to those hearings to these
hearings the people that I chase
um and I will tell you if I told my
officers to stop working nights no more
working nights you go home at five
o'clock every night in November deer
season 2 you go out at night I can
guarantee you at the end of that season
I can come in here with all honesty and
say we're not having a problem with
night hunting we're not having any
poaching going on you know why that is
folks because we don't know about it we
don't know about it when I know for a
fact it is a problem
um so those are the things I'm asking
you to consider
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
and uh if there's nobody else in the
audience who has yet to speak that needs
to speak
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on
Amendment
I am now opening the exec session for
HB
442fn and any Associated amendments
we're going to recess the exact session
movement
I'm gonna open the uh exec session
on HB 442 FN and I recognize
representative Smith for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion to
orthopass hb442fn
I'll second it myself so we can continue
moving on
um
the bill is now open for discussion and
further Amendment do I have a motion
thank you Mr chairman I motion ought to
pass on Amendment
and do I have a second on that
second that's been seconded by rep Brown
the amendment is now open for discussion
I'm going to open the floor here for
discussion does anybody want to go first
thank you Mr chair
all right
after hearing
a number of
instances of problems with this
amendment
I as one cannot support this being in
the house as long as they have it's
on the Committees I've been on to pass
legislation that is ready for prime time
and this by no means is ready for Prime
Time listening to the issues that were
brought before us
um I I came
go down all of them
um we'd be here a while
but I mean
some of the main ones I look at are just
looking on page one line 30 down to 32.
um
especially specifically line 3132 and on
to page two when it says all areas
outside zones shall be restricted to
harvesting Lobsters by those with a
scuba diver license
tells me the way that's worded is
the only ones outside the permitted
zones
to get lobsters or scuba divers
it will prohibit those
that do love commercial lobstering
I can't support that this has to be
worded much better I mean we heard from
the colonel earlier it's all about
interpretation and how it's put into
language
and this the way I read it specifically
puts that zone
into scuba diving only anything outside
the zone
make zones for the
I don't know how you
make a Zone on a body of water
other than GPS coordinates which I heard
when I specifically asked GPS doesn't
work underwater
because there are no fence lines there
are no Border Lines there are no
markings out in the ocean to determine
where that
body of water is that you can take
then I can go on to line nine on page
two
that tell us how a scuba diver
Recreation license how they will go by
the legal size and Provisions
and when I look at those rsas and I
looked at the rsas in statute
as it was being discussed and I heard a
I think two of the most specific ones
the and most important ones that were
left out
were ones dealing with spawning with
without those in here
I'm guessing it could be taken that if
someone comes up with a lobster
egg producing Lobster
they could legally take that because
it's not specific in this language that
is prohibited
lines 27 on page two talking about
I don't know where that is
I'm not sure if it's even a statue what
e regulation is
we heard about interfering with lobster
I go down to page three right at the
bottom lines 34 through 37 there are
four
rsa's referenced there
lobster trap location Lobster tracking
any person who holds a license to take
lobster under and there's four overseas
listed
while it was being discussed I pulled up
those four rsas
and what does it say in the rsas
one's a non-residential commercial salt
it is RSA
it's line
page three line
it comes back and it says specifically
this license shall not include the
taking possession Landing or transport
of Northern shrimp which requires a
license on RSA to 1149e or The Taking of
lobsters and crab which requires this
license
so it's referring to a license that is
so I'm not sure in all four of these
that are referenced in here specifically
at the end of the statute say are not
the other issue that I see is on page
four
or traps that are attached and
retrievable no person except the owner
someone authorized by the owner
and that right there throws up a red
if you have the license for the traps
we don't have a designated Lobster
license you cannot sit there and say
I'm going to have the license for these
traps
but I'm going to give permission to so
and so to go out and check my traps
I can't support that
this language was in there for a reason
that only the owner
or fishing game
can go out there or someone authorized
by the department
you're sitting here allowing a back door
for someone to allow someone else to
tend their traps
and then the final point I'll final
thing I'll point out before I go and
then I'll be done and there's more in
here that I could go for go against but
these are some of the main sticking
when I look at
line 15 on page four
it says any person who identifies a pot
trap car that
except for the taking holding the
lobster the crab and such is
to item is unattached to a boy or in
retrievable by normal medical genes and
so if I'm walking on Hampton Beach I
walk by a trap
am I in trouble for not reporting as
soon as possible the fishing game that I
so for those reasons I mean as what I
can see is
if
at all we take a vote on this it needs a
lot of cleanup
so for that those reasons mentioned I
can't support this amendment
thank you Vice chair
anyone else want to weigh in on the
I know I've come late to the party but I
just had a couple of questions and maybe
they were already answered and I and I
apologize if they were
um how can it be determined whether a
lobster was taken from a trap or not
do you mean
that a diver took a lobster from a trap
we heard testimony from uh a large
portion of the diving Community saying
that they wouldn't do that because it's
not sporting and and they are not
there to steal and that like any other
community there may be some bad apples
but that the majority of them are
concerned about the
Ocean's floor and they're down there for
the sport and that the catching of the
Lobster by stealing it from someone
else's pot is not sporting and they
wouldn't do it we heard testimony on the
other side from uh fish and game saying
that they can't see any of that and they
can't they can't tell whether that is
enforceable or not
as far as uh you know there are no
they're responsible and they wouldn't do
that and there's you know well I would
also point out that currently uh divers
are allowed to die for crab and they're
allowed to die for scallops
and if they need to be checked they get
checked when they come out of the water
not while they're in the water
underwater
representative Harvey
thank you Mr chair
um I won't be supporting this bill
either
my main objection to it is the cost that
it's going to incur on to fish and game
this is my seventh year on this
committee it's my first choice all of
those years I am very much in support of
our Fish and Game Commission they do a a
wonderful job
um with the the resources that they have
and if you look at lines 27 through 31
on the third page this is asking them to
set up a registration system for the
taking of lobsters which they don't have
right now and we heard Colonel Jordan
say that they've been working on an
online registration for two years for
your
off-road vehicle and that
so far it hasn't even happened yet but
so far that expense has been thirty
thousand dollars
I know from my seven years here on Fish
and Game
the commission doesn't have thirty
thousand dollars just laying around for
um these kinds of purposes and they
don't get money from the general fund to
fund these kind of things there's
nothing in here that
um alludes to them getting any money to
take care of some of these unfunded
mandates that's just one of them but I
know that there were many others that we
heard as the morning progressed of other
unfunded mandates and
um you know I just know from my time
being on this committee fishing game
just doesn't have that kind of money to
be
um spending on these kind of projects
and I think we as legislators need to be
conscious of that we need to be aware of
that and we need to be respectful of
that and not keep asking them to do more
and more and more with less and less and
less
um so just from a financial standpoint
as as
along with all of the other things that
are wrong with this scale but just from
a financial standpoint it's just not a
bill that we should be supporting thank
you
thank you representative and do we have
more
representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman
I also cannot support this amendment the
way it was amended
I I heard the passionate testimony from
the chief law uh enforcement officer
Colonel Jordan
and others coming from a fishing
Community
Seabrook we love our Lobster man
and we love our fishermen they have many
regulations
our efficient game department enforce
those
regulations very successfully we heard
that if this one passes is going to
disrupt their whole department because
they don't have enough money not enough
personnel and many other things we only
have 18 miles of Coastline it's working
very well it's beautiful it it is it is
sustainable our fishermen and love
students are working hard to keep it
that way we as a legislator we should
not ruin it we are responsible people
it's not about Republican or Democrat we
are responsible we have responsibility
to our fishermen and lobstermen we
thank you representative if you could
anybody else
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman just for the record uh just to
let every representative know that this
bill was submitted on behalf of a
licensed New Hampshire commercial
fisherman which I believe hasn't been
brought up at all during testimony thank
you
thank you representative representative
Rosner
um I am going to not support this bill
for many of the aforementioned reasons
especially considering that we have so
many unfunded mandates that are being
proposed with this amendment in this
bill let alone the
I feel like the verbiage uh whether it
is confusing or not thoroughly defined I
think puts an unnecessary burden on Fish
and Game to not only put this into
effect but then to continue to try and
enforce these regulations
um I find that that's going to be not
only
um a waste of our resources in time but
also in money
um I think that the issues that this
bill is trying to address are are very
positive and I wish I could support it
but I don't feel that the text here is
actually going to accomplish the end
goals that it has destined it has
determined to try and resolve
thank you representative rosener anybody
else I'm going to let people haven't
spoken yet first speak if that's okay
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman
in full disclosure you'll see my name at
the top of this amendment
um
don't let that influence you
um some of these some of the comments
that were made earlier I would like to
to point out and I think it's
I have seen quite a few bills in my time
here since 2010
that sitting on enrolled bills that
we've had to change a number of things
or a number of wordings when when
language has been um used in different
places but is synonymous I think some of
those would be occurring here if we
don't fix them in in some of the other
stages we have before we get to that
point
first one I can point out I think is
actually a typographical error if I look
at the at the original
not typographical what's the word I'm
looking for when they put in a different
different word than what we had asked
for I don't know
thank you so uh the word two online
so I think that
helps a little bit I really don't want
to go Point by Point here but there are
a couple of things that were that are
merely I don't know
I don't know whether it was a
translation era or a fact that we were
dealing
um with someone unfamiliar with the
language and fish and game when we got
to writing the amendment but some of
these things are are more just
terminology that is currently used I
think I made a note
while Colonel Jordan was speaking
earlier in testimony that there was a
word that's generally used
um
and not used in this bill and and he
pointed that out I made notes of uh of
all
yeah that was the that was the one Plain
Sight thank you Mr chairman
um
there are a couple of those things
um so I I'm if anything I'm going to
blame uh the fact that they're
unfamiliar with pure efficient game
terms maybe that went in here
um there's a couple of other places that
uh you know I did look up those rsas
that were mentioned by the Vice chair
um I don't understand why those were
included but it would be something that
I'd certainly want to talk to the
attorney about at um
in OLS because they weren't part of the
original conversation here
um
as far as
page three line 27 where it talks about
the electronic or paper registration
system
I recall in a prior session we had and
it may have been just the the original
bill
um
the divers I think had mentioned that
they
um
they know they've seen where these are
located and and I think it was the chief
biologist of the fish and game that said
well why aren't they reporting them to
us we have nothing from them
well
when you put it in here to say that they
shall do that
um and then hear that these don't exist
um it kind of you have to kind of
scratch ahead and decide
where which line you're you want to
believe do you want to believe that they
they should have done it previously or
that they can't do it because it's now
going to cost a whole lot more money to
implement some kind of system like that
I don't know
I don't know how to go with that
um I I do think I would perhaps although
I think it's a good idea to have shall
on that because this was put in in order
to
in order to alleviate
concerns down the road with this program
for reporting to take place it was also
a way for
to alleviate some of the concern that
that the lobsterman brought forth to say
um you know how much of the of our catch
are they going to take well unless you
report this stuff
how are you going to ever know if they
are taking enough to affect your
livelihood
quite frankly
the best information that we have or
that I've seen has come from those that
state closest to us Massachusetts that
has the existing system
and they also have a reporting system
as does Maine and I just read that Maine
was going to a hundred percent reporting
system
so if these things exist on either side
of us I don't know why it is that it's
such a great leap that we can't have
such a thing a reporting system here
um if nothing else they have paved the
way and maybe there is a system that we
don't have to design from scratch and
maybe we can use their system I don't
know
um but I will say that Massachusetts has
much better reporting and recording than
any other state I've seen as far as
permits either based in this chart by
trap only by diver and Trap by diver
only by a number of traps that are
fished number of hours that diving has
taken place
all of that helps us decide whether this
is viable or not in New Hampshire and
and this comes down to their numbers
saying less than one Lobster per hour
per diver
that's all that's possible based on the
currents that are around here the
visibility that's around here the fact
that you can't do this night night time
it's only during daylight hours
it is
um we're talking
we're talking less than a lobster per
hour of diving this is nothing that's
going to interfere with anyone's
livelihood or the amount of commercial
catch that's taken place
um
I can't I can't understand why this
this little drop in a teacup is uh is
causing the consternation that it is
secondly when you get into the fact of
the numbers are staggering and I think
it's only because it's under the surface
of the water that that no one can see it
I think if there was a similar process
where Hunters were losing shopping carts
in our Great Woods there would be people
picketing the state house here and and
that's virtually what we have these are
the size of shopping carts out here the
book that I had provided here with ghost
trap pictures
were taken by a diver last week
um
in 30-minute dive
and took
um I think there's only 10 or 12
pictures in there but um but it did it
in a 30 minute time period from the UNH
Pier
so it's not
difficult to create a scenario where
there's uh trash and garbage in our
in our Waters and I'm kind of shocked
and surprised that people would be
willing to vote against something that
is going to clean up our Waters to this
extent
you need the divers we've heard how
little money that that fish and game has
or that anyone else has
these are these are volunteer
residents of New Hampshire that are
willing to put their time and effort
into marking where these are and and
facilitate the removal of them it will
take years and at the time that they're
taking them out more are being created
you can argue whether it's ten percent
that that is the right number take five
percent I don't care what the magic
number is of how many traps are lost
it's a huge number
um the fellow I was walking out with was
from oceanwide he just told me about a
trap that they just pulled up in the
fall that was from 1999 that had
embedded itself in the in the
um sea floor and he said underneath what
was buried was as good as it was uh the
day it was put in the water the first
time
so this stuff exists and and we're crazy
to uh to not think about picking it up
then you go into the park I think the
first picture in there shows a card
that's that's caught in that trap
um
beyond the pictures beyond the maps
there
um that there's no way that cod's coming
out of that trap I don't care whether
you have Escape vents or not that Cod is
going to die in that trap and it is
illegal
for the diver that took that picture to
open that trap up and let that caught
out
you would be
heartless
um
to to to vote against something that's
going to eliminate what
what's going on with under the water
with these traps as far as I can see
this is an ongoing situation
um these traps collect that's why they
call them traps
um they are they are catching things
they are those things are dying and they
that dying flesh becomes bait for the
next series so
um how how we can walk away from what we
have here whether it means we cross out
a few words or even take out a paragraph
or two in order to eliminate the idea
fish and lobsters and other Critters
that are living in these things the
fellow from Ocean wide I I pushed him on
it and he said two-thirds of the traps
that they pull up have live animals in
them
the others have shells in them
so
that mirrors the study from McGill
University on the Canadian side that
said 60 percent of the traps have
um and they they were when so first as
far as to say endangered species they
had in their traps so I don't know how
what has to happen in order to meet some
of the
concerns that uh that the vice chair has
and others
if it's a Crossing out a shell and
putting a May if it's a taking out a two
and putting a from I think
just the simple fact of being able to
clean up our oceans
at the same time that more are being
added every day
is in the fact that we are allowing
divers to be able to touch traps and
remove
endangered animals that are going to die
I think is unconscionable so I will be
thank you representative uh any other
representative naughter
thank you Mr chairman I had some
constituents contact me about this
legislation we had some several very
long conversations
about it it's very important to them and
not wanting to let perfect be the enemy
of good the good and knowing that
there's 24 individuals who will further
scrutinize this legislation thoroughly
before it ever reaches the corner office
I think we should support it
thank you representative
I'm going to let others who haven't
spoken yet speak first it's the same I
told device share representative page
please
thank you um
so I was really happy that uh oceanswide
came and we got that perspective from
our neighbors in Maine I think one of
the things that was clear to me
was that that program was really a
partnership with the lobstering industry
and that they built a lot of trust a lot
of the kids in that program were the
kids of lobstermen you know and so it's
a very different kind of thing I agree
it's a success story I agree with the
problem you know I don't think we should
be leaving this derelict gear on the
bottom of the ocean I think we probably
can all agree on that but this bill
isn't just that
um it's a lot of different pieces put
together
um I think the other piece that stood
out to me is it wasn't really a
legislative solution
you know they were they were doing that
as a partnership and the question is is
this are is it our is it the are we the
best solution here for that derelict
gear problem I think is a is a is a
piece that we should consider
I also heard in talking about the
derelict gear problem a lot more
receptivity from the community from the
lobstering community
um then I had anticipated frankly we had
a couple people say yeah this is this is
a problem we think maybe you're
exaggerating the scale of the problem
here in New Hampshire because you're
comparing us to other states but this is
a problem we agree we don't want trash
in our ocean
so I don't sense a lot of resistance to
the idea that this is something that
could be worked on
so the solution I feel should involve
into the industry and
um I I applaud oceans-wide I think it's
incredible yeah let's do it here in New
Hampshire but I don't think this bill is
necessarily the pathway or this this
amendment is necessarily the pathway I
also think we're really dealing with two
totally separate bills you know we've
tethered two two things together
um and so I feel I feel like we might be
having a very different conversation
with the lobstering community if we were
here just talking about the derelict
gear issue and maybe we could do that in
a future year
um so just putting that out there out
there for everyone as we as we consider
how I vote on this thank you thank you
representative
and rep Ford
thank you chairman uh I've talked to a
lot of folks in this room and folks who
came to testify for the past two
hearings
um I'm still on I still don't know what
to do
um and how I will vote for this
particular bill and I I hear all the all
the pieces and I I see this as a kid
walking up to the fountain soda machine
at the at the restaurant right and they
just put their cup under all these
different spigots and they think it's
going to be delicious but actually it's
going to be quite disgusting and I know
for a fact it will be discussing as I've
done it as an adult
um and so I think representative page is
correct when he says that
um there are good pieces in this in this
bill there are really good pieces that I
think
um non-partisan bipartisan support could
come after on each of the pieces of this
bill
um but I'm also a foot in the door type
of guy and is this a foot in the door to
the bigger conservation p pieces
um reforming lobstering fishermen
supporting our fish and game department
all those pieces there and is this a
foot in the door
like I said at the beginning of this I
still don't know the answer to that and
I'm hoping that
um we do not
Bank our this decision in this vote on
the filtering of the Senate and the
whole house and
um another committee if it needs to go
through that to make this bill better
because a good bill is a good bill but
can we make it better
I think this Bill yes but also it's a
it's a good opportunity to get our foot
in the door to say let's get the ball
rolling because guess what the ball's
not rolling at all
um right now so how do we get the ball
rolling
um
I said all that to say I still don't
know what I'm doing and I appreciate you
chairman for the opportunity
thank you representative
um you have not yet had a chance to
speak Jonah go for it thank you Mr
chairman I I support the amendment and
will be voting out to pass on it um I
respect my friends on the other on my
side of the aisle but I I uh frankly
just think that we need to be cleaning
up our oceans this has been a derelicts
problem that has been evident and clear
and representatives Hills uh photographs
are are pretty Stark and someone who's
spent a decent amount of time on our
oceans I know that this is a problem
allowing divers to pick up uh loose
crates I think is perfectly reasonable
um and unfunded to the point of unfunded
mandates this is a policy committee and
uh the pricing the funding of this
legislation is up to the finance
committee and I would hope that we don't
vote down a good policy because of uh
something that finance will have to deal
with
um I think that we need to clean up our
oceans and I I'll be supporting the
amendment because of that
thank you representative representative
Thomas
well thank you Mr chair I just want to
put my two cents in worth here that I I
agree with the representative across
from me representative Ford I think the
proper term I would use is don't don't
let perfect be be the enemy of the good
you're too you're over to my I didn't
uh but no really uh there there may be
some things that may have to be tweaked
with the bill but we all know that once
it gets to the house no matter how
perfect this bill is we know the other
side is going to they always do
something to it so there's another
opportunity to catch up on some on some
you know minor tweaks there as well I
certainly will be supporting this bill
and I think it's a good thing
thank you representative I think we're
ready for second rounds and
here
um I just wanted to say that I concur
with my seatmate over here
um I think there are a couple of parts
to this bill as far as like using the
licensing fees for cleanup efforts and
um requiring you know the lobster boats
to make good effort at retrieving their
lost traps and
um I you know I like the piece about
saving marine life by taking care of
these abandoned traps but I wonder if
this all these parts should be a
separate bill unto itself so that the
rest of the bill where a lot of my
colleagues here pointed out have real
particular issues that are not defined
if that should be kept separately and
all this conservation piece should be a
separate bill unto itself
thank you thank you representative
working our way around
Vice chair
thank you Mr chair I will I just wanted
to
um
follow up on a comment that was made
earlier first and then I have a couple
other things to say
um was that this bill was brought
forward
with the support of the commercial
lobsterment that is correct the original
bill was with the section in it that
stated specifically the use of State
resources is prohibited no State
resource or fund should be used to
enforce lobstering regulations in
federal water that has been removed in
this amendment so it is no longer
supported by those commercial fishermen
so I just want to make sure that's clear
that they don't support this they
and
one point I want to make is
the effective date on this shall take
anyone who's been around
state government long enough knows that
when you read this and you hear about
all the procedures that have to be done
to provide for recreational diving
licenses
and all the rules that go before it
60 days is not nearly enough time to get
through Joker
won't happen
so this won't happen 60 days upon
Passage
and with that being said I mean the only
I've always been at the Assumption here
in this house and I know a lot of my
colleagues have is
we don't pass legislation that's not
ready for prime time just to move it
forward
that shouldn't be the policy
we should do our work make it correct
before sending it on there's no
guarantee you'll have a chance to get a
thank you representative representative
Harvey
um yes and I think I said this when
Colonel Jordan was here as I was reading
this I actually thought I was reading
two different bills and I think that
they need to be separated as well
um they're the conservation effort about
lobster traps should be an entirely
different conversation than rather we
allow scuba divers to take lobsters I
have a hard time putting the two
together
um and
um I definitely agree that in my short
time I've only been in the legislator
seven years I've heard over and over and
over again that you know we we should
pass good legislation and I know
um when we were talking about this the
representative used the word I don't
know a lot and if you're using the word
I don't know then this bill isn't ready
it it's an I don't know yet bill it
needs to be it needs to be fixed I I
don't think it's something that we can
do at three o'clock in the afternoon
after spending many hours listening to
it it there's Parts in it that just need
to be corrected cleaned up and and then
perhaps sent on so I think it should be
two separate bills I think it should be
cleaned up so that we pass a good bill
there's no guarantee that anybody else
will fix the things that we want fixed
the way we want them to be fixed just
because we pass them on
um and I didn't see where you said that
60 days because I was looking for it too
because that that's not going to happen
the other question I had was I maybe I
missed it in this bill but this the
scuba divers are not pulling the traps
up
as I understand it they're marking that
with a GPS which we know doesn't work
underwater
so that somebody can come back and get
that trap but they're not actually
pulling the Trap up and and disposing of
it so um so it
if we could Market maybe that would be a
good thing but we just heard many times
that underwater GPS just doesn't work so
I don't know how they're going to even
Mark that but again it even if you pass
one on the beach it says every person
shall so next time I'm at Hampton Beach
I'm going to be looking for lobster
traps to report
um
I don't think anybody in here going
against this bill is heartless I think
we are just confused by the language I
think we're confused why the two
subjects are cobbled together in the
same bill and I think all of us feel
that there's some really good points but
it could be
better
and we need to make it better before we
one second you haven't had a chance to
speak yet
thank you Mr chair to be fair you hadn't
asked yet exactly
um so a wise wiser more experienced
person than me said this morning okay I
was rep Harvey she she said
um that she was told as a freshman
legislator to make sure that whatever
Bill we're passing which is going to
become a law is enforceable
um and we've heard many times that this
as it is written in this bill right now
is not enforceable so
um I just want to remind the committee
that
what we're doing here has effects
that are then not going to be
enforceable
out in the real world I think it yeah it
it needs reworking at least
um and I agree completely with everyone
else who has pointed out that these do
seem to be two different bills I am all
in favor of separating them especially
to work on the dellar elect gear problem
um don't believe that anyone in this
room is heartless so
I know there's an issue with Daryl gear
and I'd love to see it clean up I just
think rolling it into this one bill on
two totally different topics is not
appropriate at this time thank you
thank you representative representative
Khan
thank you Mr chairman once again
once again that I was very confused also
but two different theme in the bill
there is nobody in this room who does
not support to clean up our ocean it is
very important we need to do it either
do it today or do it tomorrow we all
support that we can come back next year
we can have a bill for ocean cleanup and
we can talk about it but this one is not
about the ocean cleanup please do not
confuse get confused this is all about
taking Lobster from the ocean floor
where those Lobster was feeded by our
fishermen for their livelihood they have
their families their children they are
mortgage they are car payment we are
bringing this law to disrupt their life
and livelihood we make good legislation
also we need to think about what is good
what is bad this is a bad legislation
that is not enforceable
um also I come from uh coastal town
called Seabrook I am a 15-year member of
the Seabrook Board of slackman we
support our fishermen our Lobster men
for many years Yankee Fisher fishermen
co-op in our town land we give them
almost for free which are them one
dollar for a year we support them big
time their livelihood is a declining
industry they have a lot of regulations
we as a legislator we need to support
them and they need our support
what is going to happen you all know
probably and if you do not know I'm
going to tell you that Seabrook Beach is
the town on beach the seabook beach does
not own by state of New Hampshire we
clean up we do we maintain it and our
town is going to do everything possible
that this bill does not affect our
fishermen
and you know we'll do everything
possible you know if it is passes thank
you
thank you representative I'm going to
take a moment of privilege myself now
since I haven't had a chance to speak
because I was reminded of uh something
by by what the good representative from
Seabrook uh just mentioned and I had a
problem with some testimony that I heard
earlier but uh it is our job to listen
and not to debate with those citizens
who come in however I found it almost
egregious that a citizen who came in
would liken the allowing of divers to
take some lobsters from the ocean
to a landowner in Northern koas County
with a thousand acres of land having
someone go on his property and cut trees
because that comparison implies that the
divers believe they own all the lobsters
oh that the the lobstermen believe they
own all the lobsters and then a diver
going in is stealing their lobsters
and I'm sorry but those are a resource
for everyone the better comparison would
have been if a landowner in koas County
with a thousand acres believes that he
should stop a deer hunter from taking a
deer on his property
that's the more accurate comparison
and if the dive the landowner in co-auth
wants to post all his property all
Thousand Acres sure
stop him from taking a deer on your
property but I bet you that one deer
isn't gonna hurt as much as walking
around and maintaining those signs on a
nobody owns those lobsters they are a
resource to the state
so we all own them
and any comparison that we heard today
that makes it sound like the lobstermen
feed those lobsters raise those lobsters
and own those lobsters needs to be
stricken from our minds right away
because they may put the bait out in the
traps
it's part of their job that they've
chosen as a profession
it's not true aquaculture they're not
raising those lobsters in a seclu secure
protected environment we see some
aquaculture being done for
um
oysters right now in the Great Bay Area
and and I'll tell you the people who put
those out there depend on
keeping their stuff
isolated nobody's got access to it
they're the ones putting the seeds in
there and getting them growing and
providing the environment
uh they're just using our Waterway to
grow their their oysters so it's much
different with free roaming lobsters
that are roaming around there all
together
just like nobody could say they own the
Cod and nobody can say they own the The
Flounder
so I want to make it clear
the comparison that's appropriate in
that case is deer hunting not cutting
the trees that somebody personally owns
on their property
and so I just wanted to put that out
there as a distinction
um before anybody gets
further involved in the whole lobsterman
on the lobsters at lobsterman feed the
lobsters they're the lobsterman's
lobsters
they're all of our lobsters I don't have
a boat so I can buy the five pot but I
think the colonel will yell at me if I
go out and start throwing the pots in
from off the shore I'd have to go out in
a boat first and drop them in
um that's all I had
I'll recognize rep Smith
thank you Mr chair we've heard some
great testimony I think we beat this to
death can I ask to move the question on
this
no I don't think it's appropriate at
this time we still have some vigorous
discussion going on but it will be very
very soon here uh because I think we're
down to our last two people okay I just
I see like two people left uh I'll go
with you Jonah for one quick thing thank
you Mr chairman I just really quickly
want to say in response to what
representative Khan said sometimes
interests conflict and what's best for
the industry may not be best for our
oceans and the industry has been putting
crates with no recourse whatsoever into
our oceans and leaving them as
representative Hill said as early as in
some cases 1999 so I think requiring the
industry to keep track of those and
making a good and make and having them
make a good faith effort to recover them
is exactly what we need to be doing and
sometimes what's best for Industries and
what's best for the state
thank you representative and I think
it'll take you representative Hill is
the last question or comment
is there thank you
did you need something to represent Rome
okay let's let Brown go first he's not
spoken much and he's been taking our
notes so vigorously
uh thank you Mr chair I wanted to
address what uh representative Harvey
said for those that weren't here earlier
today just to be clear you can't take a
GPS underwater and locate something
that's correct well one of the divers
said was they would pop up a water
bottle on a line or a buoy of some
nature on a line that would Mark where
the plot was in the bottom and then
potentially GPS it or let the lobsterman
know where fish and game know that that
buoy was there
thank you thank you and now we'll go to
representative Hill to finish us off
before we take the role thank you uh
representative Brown had me cross off
one thing off my list
um I wanted to point out that uh that
these divers that came to speak to you
today
um are New Hampshire residents and
following along somewhat with the
Chairman's um
uh discussion point on the fact that uh
no one owns the lobsters
um there's just um people that generate
their livelihood for it from it but
these people are looking for a way of of
doing what every other state with the
exception of Maine on the East Coast
currently does
um
it's it's kind of
amusing to listen to uh some of the
online uh scuba diving areas and and
people cannot believe what New Hampshire
is doing in this regard
um they do understand Maine however I
don't understand that part but that's
you're right I do use understand I don't
understand but here's something I do
understand we have in our application
for
licenses for lobster and crab in New
Hampshire we have
um a checkoff box for whether you are a
resident or a non-resident
um and you are able to get a
non-resident commercial license a
limited commercial license a part-time
uh commercial license
um and even a no I guess you can't get a
lobster helper license is a non-resident
but but for six hundred dollars this
says with the asterisk that you belong
to a a state that has reciprocal
agreements which we have with Maine and
New Hampshire
um for six hundred dollars they can get
a non-resident
commercial license that entitles them I
believe to a thousand traps
so we are willing to allow New Hampshire
um to sell to non-residents
um
Lobster Lobster licenses and not allow
divers from uh who wherever in New
Hampshire the opportunity to take three
lobsters for their own personal loose
use as a as a sport I don't understand
that at all secondly
um
we yet we it is true we are a policy
committee here
um those of you that sit on it full time
um
I am pledging to you as the sponsor and
as a co-sponsor of the amendment
um you do have the ability to have uh
influence on how this bill changes as it
goes through the process I can't
remember a single bill in my time here
since 2010 that the bill that was seen
by the initial policy committee was the
bill that came out of the sausage
machine at the other end without any
changes in it
um it it constantly has something in
there I am telling you that I'm
available anytime that anybody wants to
change anything in this bill and we'll
have a discussion about it we do have uh
I don't know how any two or three or
four more
I hate the phrase but bites at the Apple
we have the ability to make these
changes throughout the process so I
don't have a problem listening to anyone
in in any of these uh issues that were
brought up that includes fish and game
if they would like to uh contact me
which I've never had happen
um with that I think I'll end my
testimony and I'll go from there thank
you and representative Khan if it's new
ground I'd be willing to entertain the
comment because it seems like we're
starting to churn the same things and I
don't want to continue with that process
Mr chairman thank you I just want to
make sure that everybody's in the same
page we heard the testimony from
licensing Authority that Outsider a
visitor or another State's residents
cannot have any license in New Hampshire
I want to have that on the record that
that is true or not
no no can we hear from the licensing
Authority Mr chairman
we can quickly hear that I believe
though I could probably save her walking
up because I believe that uh her comment
was that no other state is giving us
reciprocity at this time so therefore
it's a moot point and we can't sell the
license because of the requirement that
we sell to a reciprocal state so
although we have the license category
and the license category is listed and
purchasable the purchase is dependent
upon the other state also having a
reciprocal out of state commercial
Lobster license that does not currently
exist
so
does that stop you from having to walk
up thank you I'm glad I have a good
memory
and I will just very quickly hit rep
forward as long as again it's new ground
that we haven't touched already because
I'd like to move us forward I just want
to know just to make clear the OTP was
on the amendment and the bill correct
so the way that this goes because you're
a freshman I'll explain and there's more
freshmen here
um you have to move the amendment to be
able to amend it it has to be a positive
movement on the amendment on the I mean
the bill so the bill was moved OTP to
allow it to be open for an amendment the
amendment was then put forward as OTP so
that we could discuss the amendment the
vote currently is on the amendment when
we finish we will then have a vote on
go ahead
representative Hill I just want to say
we have passed bills any DNA this year
without amending them so come on over if
representative Khan no
representative Smith
yes
representative Tudor
representative noter yes
representative Brown yes representative
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Thomas yes
representative Harvey
no
representative wheeler
yes
representative Ford
representative O'Brien
no
representative massamila
representative Morton no
representative page no
representative rosener
yes
uh if my if I'm corrected is yes 13 no
seven
the motion is now otpa on the underlying
Bill ought to pass as amended and I will
order the clerk to call the roll
oh the who was first and second on the
motion for the bill itself I know that
Smith was first and I've seconded the
motion on I did so that it could be
Vice chair goalie
no
representative Khan
representative Smith yes representative
Hill
yes
representative Tudor
representative norter yes
representative Brown yes representative
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Thomas yes
representative Harvey
no
representative wheeler yes
representative Ford yes
representative O'Brien
no
representative massamila
representative Morton no
representative page no
representative rosener
yes
and chair representative chairman
Spillane
yes
that number would be the same 13. yes
seven no will there be a Minority Report
yes there will be a Minority Report that
is due to the assistance office by
end of the day or first thing tomorrow
since it was so late I'll give you a
little extra time
and representative Smith will you be
writing a majority report perhaps with
the help of representative Hill since he
knows the subject inside and out
and sideways who was for minority
minority report is being written by well
he can tell you who it's going to be
though
would do you have someone in mind at
representative Harvey will do the
Minority Report
for your paperwork okay
I want to thank everybody for coming
Mr chair wasn't paying attention since I
didn't think it was me what where am I
supposed to send my report to to our
assistant by the by tomorrow morning and
the assistant is
uh what's her name again uh Jamie
Jamie committee assistant
j-a-m-i she she's in the same office
and Mr director I'm still trying to fit
in your last two people to talk to the
committee
but I did want to mention to everybody
in the committee while you're here and
even I guess the substitutes because
you'll be jealous we are working on two
field trips for the committee we want to
go to owls Brook
uh Al Brook and we're also working with
uh representative Brown here who used to
be a member of Des to uh survey the area
where the the Senate has decided to put
a bill in to ask us to build a boat ramp
and then to also take a tour on the Des
boat to see some of the areas that we do
for cleanup and what the process is on
our shorelines
so um both of those will be in warmer
weather and TBD but we'll look for some
help with you for the AL Brook situation
[Laughter]